All right,
we're live.
All Right,
ladies and gentlemen.
Vinny shoreman.
How are you buddy?
Hello.
I'm fine.
How are you?
Good,
good.
Pull that microphone right up.
Get it right up there.
Um,
we just did a hypnosis is hypnosis
session.
I will.
How would you call it?
Hypnotic session.
Just a sexual stuffed mental training
mind stuff.
I'm vinny is the man that,
uh,
Joe Schilling,
experienced,
uh,
some fantastic results doing this with
you.
Joe Schilling,
who's the world champion,
kickboxer beltour fighter guy who's been
in here before and he told me about you
and you and I went back and forth on
twitter and email and then we finally
got together today and today's hypnosis
session.
And I'm here to tell Ya,
hypnosis is real.
It does.
You definitely go under.
There's something happens.
You go to some weird dream.
Stay at la La land.
How long was that?
Under four.
Four and a half days now.
You were hungry to be honest about,
I'd say 20 minutes.
Twenty minutes.
Maybe 20 minutes.
Thirty minutes.
You can kind of get lost in it too,
you know,
it seems like it seemed like five.
No,
it was longer than that.
Yeah,
it was good enough.
It was like I remember the beginning
part and then all of a sudden it was
over.
I was like,
whoa.
And there was some weird dream state
stuff going on in the middle where you
were talking about some things,
but I was thinking about other shit,
but I was.
When I was thinking about shit,
I was like,
wow,
I'm in a weird state of mind right now
while I'm thinking about these other
things.
Like I better get back on track about
what vinny?
No,
probably not.
I think it's funny because it's.
I've done everything that I do with my
clients and you've experienced,
I've experienced and he put it right is
weird.
Yeah.
It's weird because it's.
It works definitely works well.
There's different states that the brain
operates in.
We all know that are states when you're
stressed out their states,
when you're super happy,
there states when you're very focused
the states and you're in danger of the
states and you're in love and we all
know that these are weird places that
your brain can go to.
Weird frequencies are weird vibrations,
whatever you would call it,
but to be able to manipulate it like
that,
to be able to put someone into a state
like that or help them,
assist them getting into a state like
that.
That's a very,
very unique skill.
Yeah.
I mean,
oh hell hypnosis yourself at Nell's.
He's anyway,
so you do it.
I just guide you into it,
you know,
and give you ways of just going into
hypnosis is a natural state.
Although he said,
we said it was talking earlier like you
know you're driving and all of a sudden
you end up there and you think shit out
to get there.
I don't do that because I'm rubbish at
driving,
but you know other things where you
just.
It just seems it.
Televisions,
hypnosis,
music set.
Notice that all different states and
we're all in different states all the
time.
So I'm,
I'm like a movie that just captures you
and you don't even realize you're
watching it.
You're just totally.
You're
inside,
you're completely absorbed in the film.
That's almost like a hypnotic state.
Definitely mean clumping for Superman
for instance.
We know safe mother's next six exist,
fortunately,
I'm sorry to break in one's let's mom,
but you know,
it's just a part and parcel of using
your imagination to get you to a place
where you want to change.
So,
but,
but that state that you achieve when
you're,
when you hypnotize someone,
when you put someone in this really
relaxed place and you have them focus on
very specific things and you get them to
this weird state where your mind is
drifts off into dreamland.
That's very different than a movie are
very different than driving home in your
car.
It's,
uh,
it's,
it's pretty intense.
Yeah,
it is.
They're all,
they're all imaginative processes
anyway.
You know,
they're all my cheeses.
Processes.
But with hypnosis,
you focusing on a specific properly.
Normally,
you know,
you focus on a specific treatment.
So lit is the lead into it.
It depends.
It depends on what the client is.
Um,
I don't always use hypnosis.
I am a mind coach.
Don't class myself as a hypnotist.
Although hypnotherapy is part and parcel
of why date,
I class myself as a mind coach because
he's different facets to it.
These different ways of leading people
into fairies things and considerations
about what they say,
especially using language when it's out
of sync sort of thing.
Does it make sense?
And then you might have to make sense of
it and then unconsciously you
unconscious mind deciphers it and gets
you the best results really.
Well,
it's,
it's fascinating to me because for the
longest time mine coaches were sort of
unheard of in combat sports.
It was almost like it was a,
uh,
a scarlet letter or a,
you know,
a mark against you because you were so
weak that you needed someone to figure
out how to hypnotize you or how to talk
you into being strong.
You needed a car.
You should just be a fucking man and get
out there and do it.
Right.
Like that was the attitude that a lot of
people had.
Yeah.
In England say dealt with a fucking soft
Glendale or.
I say that in America too.
Yeah.
But they don't say it with that show to
say with the same company to company
telling them from the north.
What I mean,
it was a yeti solid macho,
you know,
don't you know,
get on with it,
blah,
blah.
I've seen more people,
a lot of very,
very skilled get beat by their own self.
You say not,
you know their own minds and then they
can be very.
It can be very hard for people.
The reason why I was going to bring that
up because I think that fighting in
particular is probably the most
difficult of all chosen endeavors
outside of being a soldier is the most
difficult of all chosen,
chosen endeavors as far as chosen goals
that you're trying to accomplish.
What you're trying to accomplish is you
try to use your body,
use your bones and your muscle to defeat
other people who are also using their
bones and muscle and the techniques are
all readily available.
There's no secrets anymore.
I mean there's a few secrets.
If you have a really good coaches,
you can get some tips,
but essentially everybody knows how to
punch.
Everybody knows how to kick and you're
just trying to figure out how to
maximize your possibilities,
maximize your potential for victory and
how to not get in your own way,
not how to not trip over your own fears
and anxiety.
And that's where this mind coach thing
comes into play.
And that's where I think it's applicable
not just for fighting,
but also for just life in general
because I think that for a lot of
people,
their success or failure,
a big part of it is predicated on how
they view life and how they view
themselves and how they approach each.
Each thing,
each obstacle,
each,
uh,
each goal,
each endeavor that they,
they,
they're attempting to,
uh,
to solve or to give their own expression
too.
And I think that if it works on
fighting,
it'll probably work on anything.
And if you can get someone to a better
place mentally where they can become a
more effective fighter and stay out of
their own way,
has terms of their anxiety and their
fears,
like the reality of fighting is you're
probably going to get hurt at some point
in time.
It's just part of what you're doing.
You're in the hurt business,
this is the hurt game,
and somewhere along the line you're
going to get hit and you're,
you're hopefully going to hit the other
person more than they're going to hit
you.
But bad things happen to great fighters.
We've all seen it.
Yeah,
I mean,
Ace is part and parcel of everything.
You know,
if I could make.
It's not just about fires.
I mean I'll do what with fights is
because I come from a background.
I've been involved in it a long time,
30 years now.
And um,
it's,
you have to find things out as you know.
Well,
of course,
but finding yourself as well as an
opponent as well as trying to listen to
Econ as well as hearing people scream
your name or other people screaming for
them or the person to kick your ass.
It's difficult.
You have to,
you have to kind of go with it,
you know,
and,
and control everything that you do and
then try and impose what you've got to
do on the other person.
You had doubts and fear.
They're extra weights that you carry
into the ring,
yeah,
or into the cage and in life and again
it's analogous to life doubts and fears
on top of the reality of the difficulty
of what are you're trying to do.
Whatever you're trying to do,
those doubts and fears,
they're like,
it's like a heavy weight vest that
you're carrying on top of the burden of
whatever you're trying to accomplish in
the first place and for fighters it can
be just smothering it,
getting it.
I mean we've.
We've had many instances of guys
backstage that either didn't fight or
almost didn't fight because they're
having anxiety attacks because they were
freaking out because the moment was
finally there and their mind was just
running away from them.
Just your mom was trying to figure out a
way out of this.
We can figure out a way out of this.
All we have to do is just go crazy here
and the doctor will come over and you
know,
how about you have a few heart
palpitations and fall down and you can't
breathe,
and then the doctor's going to rescue
you.
Fighting to find something wrong.
With me,
because a male,
everyone's considered though I did the
same thought,
you know,
if he sees something male,
male and then you don't have to go in
there,
but you know,
it's about controlling the fight so it
wouldn't last in the changing rooms
sometimes.
A lot of the time,
you know,
be the most self confident you can be
the most confident motherfucker on
earth.
But if you're fighting Anderson Silva
and his prime and you're not that good,
you're probably still going to get lit
up and that's a problem.
I mean,
you can make yourself look as bad as you
could as you would if you didn't do
anything about,
you know,
maybe you know,
there's only so much.
Yeah,
there is.
I mean,
not everyone's going to be a champion.
That's fact.
That is a finale,
you know,
but they don't throw these belts around
day.
The UFC and the WBC boxing,
they don't just give you about,
you know,
and there's always.
But from my point of view,
I like seeing people conquer,
share that really debilitating.
Whether they win,
lose or draw.
Sometimes it's respective.
It's the experience,
all of them saying,
I did lot better than I thought I would
do when you know and and all that sort
of stuff,
and they can live with it.
Some people lose and they just never
forget it and it can hold them for real.
That's not real.
Yeah.
They defined themselves.
That's a real issue with human beings.
They define themselves with their past
failures.
Even though they've learned from those
mistakes,
they always look at themselves.
It's like,
God,
I'm the guy who did this.
I'm the guy who shit his pants.
I'm the guy who got in that car
accident.
I'm the guy who showed up late and got
her.
I got fired from my job and you become
instead of a human being who has a
lifelong,
just a giant string of experiences,
a lot of them that you've learned from
and that you're better because of
instead you have the sting,
like the emotional sting of those
failures that just haunt people and
that's very common with people that they
get haunted.
That's why some people are haunted by
high school,
by,
by grammar school and high school
bullies being bullied,
like define them during their formative
state.
And uh,
you know,
I've known a lot of fighters who,
they've carried chips on their shoulders
deep into their forties from being
bullied when they were in high school.
Funny Story,
um,
when I lived in a place in England
called Michael's field and it's on a big
hill where I used to live on a scene.
The guy who's lived next door to me,
his mom use limits,
tells me Easter lived out as well.
He was 60 something like that and I seen
him at the top of the road and he was
sort of surprised and he was looking
down at the bottom of the road like
this.
He was looking again and he just stood
there and I understand what you're
doing.
And when these two guys down there,
they used to bully me at school and my
firm to go 60,
60 years of age still I'm waiting for
them.
He was waiting for them to go.
Billy's name is.
And he was just stood there and waited
for them to go that I,
I liked to change and I will look to a
change.
It's sad.
Think about it.
It's a long time,
you know,
for him to,
and he's so small town Michael's feel
worries to live.
So he's probably bumped into them.
It's probably avoided them in the store
and shops or whatever for 42,
43 years.
He says maybe,
maybe,
maybe more because before then.
And I hate that.
I just,
you know,
it's sad,
it's real sad
situation,
but it also seems to be bizarrely and
cruelly,
a part of human nature and common part
of animal nature with the animals.
Fuck with other animals.
They try to find the pecking order and
it motivates the weak ones to be strong.
It motivates people to stand up for
themselves.
And that's where the bullying is a
horrible thing.
But bullying is also the reason why a
lot of great fighters exist.
Guys like George St Pierre.
I mean he's pretty open about it.
Like the reason why he became a great
fighter because he was tired of people
fucking with him and he might not have
ever become the guy who he became if it
wasn't for that pressure,
if it wasn't for those obstacles that
are thrown in front of his face,
you know,
and that's,
it's a very,
it's,
it's unfortunate that it happens.
But objectively,
if you step back and look at just life
itself,
it seems to be an inexorable part of our
existence on this planet.
There's a pull and a push and if there's
no one pushing,
there's no Poland and if there's no,
you know,
you know what I'm saying?
If there's no,
there's no negative.
Oftentimes the positive doesn't reach
the same heights.
No,
it doesn't.
Um,
and a lot of cases.
But if he can chip away at it or at
least change some perspective on it for
a person.
This is why someone said to me,
one,
certainly want it to be a mind coach
that I'm only gonna work with athletes.
I'm not going to,
I'm going to do therapy.
So all therapy cell therapy,
regardless if fighters,
it's not always about them being noticed
about fight in the finders and scatter.
It might be something to do with the
girlfriend,
a loss of a family member,
whatever,
you know,
it goes back way back to solve part of
people's journeys.
It's all part of people being who they
are.
Therapy has a negative connotation in a
lot of people's minds because they
connected to self indulgence.
Like go,
you're going to go to therapy every day
and just whine and bitch about your
life.
And Yeah,
we've all met people that are doing
that.
You know,
we've all met people that are just
locked.
So for them it's sort of more about
having opportunity to use someone to
talk about themselves.
It's an ego trip in a lot of ways.
Instead of trying to solve whatever,
whatever influences that they have
control over them.
Say that again.
He gets to know as a mind coach.
She gets to know who will do carry on
doing that behavior,
that secondary gay.
Some people do their behavior just for,
again,
just to,
you know,
get themselves where they want to get is
get really.
Once again,
it's a kind of decide from that I don't
really,
I don't play that game.
I just kept them,
you know,
really,
and it just kind of,
they can be kind of tough with it,
but you know,
if you want them to change,
if they don't want to change,
nothing you can do,
you know,
I don't want,
I don't have these dragged out long
therapy sessions of and then this and
this and this happened in the up and I
try and get right to it,
right to the right to the core of it.
And I'm like,
because the way I was trained,
I was trained by a guy called Collin Mci
who's absolutely like Yoda,
you know,
my teacher and I was trained.
I was trained that way and they see us.
Good success.
And you,
how did you get involved with him?
Um,
I got involved with Colin.
Uh,
I started,
I went to a seminar many years ago by a
guy called Keith Mayer and I was a bad
time in my life,
been a bit of an idiot in snow,
in dancing powder,
etc.
I wasn't being the best it could be
under.
I went to a seminar,
Keith Mayer loved it,
felt great,
didn't know why.
I just really started reading books,
everything,
Dr.
Wayne Dyer and all sorts of things like
that.
And then,
um,
I got older,
I wanted to do a course with a,
with a company and the company was gone,
but I found out about colin and that was
it.
Since then he's become a friend and
we're like east,
just small,
super small.
Well,
it's interesting because your main
pursuit with this or your main focus
with this as fighters,
so you're,
you're dealing with a very concentrated
version of this kind of problem solving
because of the fact that the existence
is so intense.
It's so difficult.
Psychologically.
It's so difficult emotionally and it's
very difficult physically as well.
There's so many dIscipline.
There's.
So,
there's so many factors involved in,
in being a successful fighter.
And you were involved in probably like
the most,
the most concentrated form of dealing
with anxiety and problem solving and the
ability to see results.
It's,
yeah.
To be honest,
I never thought of it like that.
I didn't because I've been around it so
long.
I never really thought of it like that.
I just do what I do.
Well,
if you think about it,
like the person,
like say if a guy was I'm a banker or an
insurance salesman or something like
that,
and they had a bunch of issues that are
Keeping theM back from being successful
in their chosen endeavor.
The,
their,
you know,
their failure pro
or con is only financial,
you know,
relative to them,
isn't it?
It is relative to that.
The intensity of it.
Yeah,
like the intensity of a guy going into
battle like yourself about to go and
trying to find coughs and reasons why
someone's going to step in and rescue
you from what is ultimately your entire
focus for the last six to eight weeks.
You've been ready for this one moment
and the moments here and you're ready to
get the fuck out of there.
Right.
There's nothing like that in the world
of noodles.
Bankers suppose is not because I've been
around so long.
It's been around it a way.
Tie sound.
So many scenes.
How many read he could fight isn't a
gym.
I also think in pot shop clenched.
Every famous sweet spiring was on point
and then just to see this different.
I think of it like they should.
I really like making a really nice
wedding cake and then when you can show
it to the people are going to the
wedding just fucking squash yet.
So I always felt like,
to me it's just like just destroyed our
own creation.
All the stuff that they've done in the
gym.
Maybe a better analogy is you will,
you will that wedding cake out and it
melts instantly under the hot lights on
the stage,
which is really what it is because when
you have it in a regular room,
the lights aren't that hot and when you
have someone in the gym,
I mean,
there's a lot of pressure sparring and
the gym of course,
you know,
there's a lot of,
uh,
there's great fighters.
You're working out with people who were
very dangerous.
There's a lot of expectatIons and
anxiety,
but it's nothing compared to an actual
fight itself.
That's when everything's ramped up.
Yeah,
I mean,
especially like you said,
there's people that I've been bullied as
well and you have to consider who you
are.
You have to consider everything about
yourself,
you know,
going on that stage,
going into that lion's den,
so to speak.
And you know,
the gladiatorial sort of archetype of it
all.
But um,
it's,
it's difficult,
but there is techniques at work really,
really well maintained techniques that
work really well to get the person out
of these negative states of mind,
these negative patterns to get them to
get them because what can happen as you
can go away with a train of thought so
it might be five and goes on and on gets
bigger and bigger and bigger than the
south salt gets really intense so it
trips you up completely and then can
overthrow you to make you a minimum of
what you can actually achieve.
You know what I mean?
And you've recently started working with
my friend ian mccall,
who was another great ufc fighter.
He's very excited about the results.
Very happy about the results.
All right,
good.
I'm glad about that.
He loves it.
Yeah.
We were talking about it and he was
like,
I'm 100 percent sold a real,
you know,
when I first try,
he said when he first started doing it,
he was like,
eh,
we'll see.
But then,
you know,
once he really experienced it,
he was like,
okay,
I'm going to be doing this from now on.
Yeah,
he's,
I really like him because he's a real
nice guy.
Um,
we've not done that much.
Rarely did you work with them after his
last fight?
Did you work with them after the.
I've only been,
I actually don't know because,
you know,
no disrespect to the avid followed us.
I know.
I'm sorry,
I'll leave now,
but I'm finished my coffee first.
But uh,
but he's like,
you know,
um,
I think it was after his last loss.
He said he was feeling things.
Yeah.
Was that the guy?
A little stocky guide and just winning
shots in jada?
I,
yeah,
I did see that.
And um,
since working with them it's just,
it's just about finding out who they
are.
Everyone is different and that's why I
liked to work with people once I want to
do seminars.
I'm over here doing some else at the
moment,
but like to work with people to find out
what makes them tick,
to find out what stimulates them and
what doesn't,
you know.
And we'll hold them up.
Yeah,
definitely.
But ian mccall's a lovely guy.
I really,
really liked him.
And joe,
same thing.
Yeah.
Same people.
Same deal.
Yeah.
And you work with ross pearson as well
as another
done.
I worked with ross person.
I was,
I did some stand up.
I used to teach my tie.
It was at a gym called salford moitai
on.
I'm just holding pads.
And so I kind of fell out of love with
it,
really teaching,
etc.
because mine coaching took over it.
But yeah.
What would ross as well,
he didn't have a super guy.
So you're not doing muay thai training
anymore.
You basically do an online coach stuff
now.
Commentary for infusion.
And for folks who don't know,
vinnie useD to do commentary for each
shoW time,
which is one of the bigger kickboxing
events in the world before it was bought
out by glory.
And uh,
and um,
now it's,
uh,
gloria is struggling a bit and uniteD
states,
unfortunately,
I don't know why.
It's just to me,
I'm such a huge fan of it.
I think,
uh,
you know,
you watch a fight like simon marcus
versus um,
a arts and levin is a fucking great
fight.
I was watching it this morning again,
and the gym was amazing.
Amazing fight.
Five rounds.
Went to a draw.
Yeah.
I mean he's just a fucking war between
two of the very best guys in the world.
So exciting high level stuff.
I've never seen anyone trailer.
I was in America last year with my
friend brian dobler from fontana.
I was,
he was training their assignment was
trading at his gym.
I've never seen anyone train like men.
She really,
you know.
Oh,
well,
he looks like a machine.
Yes.
Yeah,
it does.
Yeah.
And his fight with joe schilling.
Holy shit.
What a fight.
That was.
Yeah.
And joe wound up knocking him out in the
fourth round.
They went three rounds.
It was a draw after three rounds and joe
knocked him out in the for this fucking
crazy
joselyn get salt.
This jail shit is like the guy up
halloween,
Michael Myers came down.
He's getting buck up and he's special.
And you were working with him before
that fund was?
I worked with them before the first
glory.
When he won it.
Would it be the altima?
Yeah,
I,
I asked him.
I met joe.
uh,
it,
it was kind of,
I don't know,
I'll be honest with you,
gerard,
a bit of a chip on his shoulder.
He was angry and stuff,
you know what I mean?
He won't mind me telling you this
because he said I can swap beat me up.
And um,
he,
yeah,
he was,
um,
It was a bit like that and I seen him at
k one because I did k one in los angeles
while ago.
I was talking to him.
I said,
your miles better than what you come
across on the internet.
You're much better person than what you
act on it.
Kind of stuck home with him.
He made me a friend on facebook and then
a concept statement said,
you know,
joe,
want me to work wIth you?
And he went,
yeah,
sure.
Cool.
And then we got on.
He's so smart.
He picks things up so quickly,
so open to stuff.
We've done some really,
really cool stuff that's I can
experiment on joe,
if,
if that makes sense.
You know,
some things I want to try.
I a dude him and he seems to work really
well on him.
So can you give us an example?
Like what do you mean?
Like things that you want to explain it.
It's really strange,
but he's like,
I had to think about,
because I'm,
I'm english of sir galahad.
They night gala hearts,
you know,
the knights of the round table,
king arthur and joel didn't want to get
injured because he was gonna fight.
I think you've robert something or
other.
He was fought on,
on gloria and then he was going to fight
on ballots or against melvin mom have
any anyway to come out unscathed.
So we persuaded his unconscious mind to
have armor likes the gullah heart.
So I talked in hypnosis about the
archetype of knights,
of the knights of the round table.
And he will struggle a heart.
Not literally obviously,
but you know,
so we had armor so he didn't come.
So we come out on injured,
you know the words,
I'm not saying it's going to work for
everything,
you know,
like I'll get,
you know it bullets and stuff like that,
you know what I mean?
But it was just,
it was getting his mindset into that,
into that sort of the way of thinking.
He was so worried about getting injured.
So the,
is that why it was effective?
Because it mitigated the stress that he
worried about getting injured.
A sideline can fuck you.
God,
I don't get her.
I'll get her to that getting hurt.
He's in the back of your mind replaying
over and over and over again.
yeah,
indeed.
There was one instance,
liam harrison was fight and it's cycled
cal some that I need for him before and
got stopped in Jamaica and john wayne
power for,
against ballpark walk out.
Pulper moc and I'm leaving had been
stopped and it was a forefront with low
kicks.
So we did a hypnosis to make him called
hypnosis in a triggered was warrior.
You know,
we kept this work because liam's,
if you ever seen liam harrison fires,
incredible fire.
And along with Jordan Watson and andy
house and all them from bud company in
england.
And um,
what,
what we did was we did,
they said no,
she said when I was coming saying on the
show because he was fighting unaware in
round four and it just freaked me out
really to be honest.
He looks at me and he looked me straight
in the eye and he went worrier and then
beat shit out of anyone when I'm points
and yeah,
afterwards I said,
you remember saying worry anyway.
No,
I didn't remember it.
So it was that stuCk in his hat.
That was that.
Well,
in all fairness,
he probably got hit in the head a bunch
of charts.
No,
I have no fucking idea who I am.
I mean,
how many times is a fighter won a fight
and then asked what happened?
Yeah.
That
does happen.
But I feel that I just state as well as
both,
right?
Yeah.
We Saw them up a state that had not
extended it.
Yeah,
that's what I.
Isn't it in the japanese martial arts,
I think you said it's a state.
Did mohammed ali talk about it when
muhammad ali fought cleveland williams,
he was in that side kind of state.
You know what's my favorite ali fight?
I'm so glad you brought that up,
is just any breathtaking.
I've played that fight on this podcast
at least three times in a state.
It was in this flow and that's before he
went away for three years before they
took away his ability to fight cause he
wouldn't fight in the Vietnam war.
And then he came back and he was never
the same again.
That cleveland williams fight to me is
like quintessential and people should
watch,
let's just showed his,
his full potential.
But yeah,
he was in that sort of flow state,
but now way to get the same,
you know,
he's the way he's.
I mean he,
there's one fight,
harold brazier,
he moved up to light welterweight to
remember and he slipped,
slipped out of debit.
I can't do it by like they slipped,
slipped and they just steps around him
and pat him on the ass and I'm like,
come on now.
That's ridiculous skill.
Yeah.
Well,
whittaker is one of those guys that
people kind of forget about,
you know,
like everyone wants to talk about julio,
cesar chavez and some great fighters
from that era.
You just have as that I think you want
as well.
But uh,
he was one of those guys that for
whatever reason,
people have kind of forgotten about him.
Meldrick taylor,
a lot of people have forgotten about
them.
Algebra taylor taylor were meldrick
taylor.
I shouldn't say this.
When meldrick taylor last to christina
spanner and I think he fought in Ireland
or somewhere.
Oh no,
it was on.
They raise the roddick and lennox lewis.
Bill.
I cried.
I loved meldrick taylor.
He was like my everything.
It was,
I shouldn't say that.
She was like,
oh no,
no.
But he was just.
I loved watching him fight with chavez
was just classic.
Yeah.
Well chavez changed him.
He was never the same after that fight.
No,
after he got stopped in the twelfth with
like seconds to go,
richard blow to something else and that
he was swallowing his own blood from the
mouth cuts.
But it was just,
it was heartbreaking because after that
he was just literally never the same.
And I remember right now race destroy
interiors is bouncing on his feet and,
and then Terry Terry,
now he's fucking out.
They're both fucked it just training,
training,
training.
Golovkin isn't who his trainer.
Abel sanchez.
He's now training them up in big.
I love,
love,
love can explain how he fights.
He always talks about how he feels and
emotion.
He talks about how he feels and
everything.
You see him,
even when he's in the park,
he seemed feeling the shot,
you know,
he said he,
he can see him every single part of them
considering everything that he does.
And apparently he's even beats people
up.
I think kai,
that kovalev at last,
at last have left that gym because of
gennady golovkin.
It really drops into the body shot.
Yeah.
He's a monster Who fights 15 pounds.
Heavier.
Real.
I'm not saying it's rumors.
Spread it up,
spread it.
Even england anymore in liverpool.
I've moved kovalev and knocking on the
doors.
It was joe rogan's fault.
He made me say it.
Kovalev was a monster to incredible and
will quite dear to bernard hopkins.
That was pretty shocking,
pretty shocking to see bernard hopkins
and fully defensive survival mode.
Especially in round 12.
I fought,
it,
looked like it.
He let him off a bit in rounds,
rather thought I thought he was chasing
him down.
I didn't know was very.
At least it's on my friend's facebook
and it yet I think names,
but he,
um,
was before he was famous and uh,
but he seems to like violent stuff,
you know,
it's a scary guy.
He's a very,
very scary guy.
Well,
he killed the guy in the ring one,
a guy died and one of his fights.
I didn't seem to affect him at all.
You know,
a lot of times like with raymond sini
or,
um,
emil griffith,
there's a lot of fighters.
They'll kill somebody if I remove
quickened did as well.
Didn't it can kill somebody as well.
It didn't remember that.
Yeah.
But if something happens to them after
that where they're never quite the same.
Ben,
ben was the same night.
It's interesting,
again,
general mcclellan fund,
if you listen to that,
at the end of it he said says the first
person I'd like to thank paul mckenna,
hypnotizing me and making me believe in
myself,
and I met nigel been about two months
ago and I said that after you watch it,
the first thing you said,
I'd like to thank paul mckenna for
hypnotize me and I can believe him
though,
because they apparently had a separation
of his wife and his girlfriend now fucks
people up,
you know,
so there's a,
there's a grief attached to it,
isn't that,
you know,
and um,
yeah.
Nigel and I mentioned that to nigel
banks have massive fan and I mentioned
that.
I said I got into mind coaching because
partly it's because of how,
you know what,
let me go out the ring.
He got knocked out of the ring the first
round.
The mcclellan was just a monster.
Now was in his prime and to destroy your
back then.
And they were,
everyone was talking about mcclellan
eventually fighting Roy Jones jr.
It was the big super far that was on the
horizon,
sort of like,
you know,
people are anticipating all the
different fights right now for golovkin
anticipating possibly kodo kodo.
Maybe one day I'm canelo canelo alvarez.
Yeah,
that's a possibility and that's how they
were looking at him until the nigel band
fight and it looked like he was just
going to kill nigel benn just just
beating the fuck out of him,
but two things.
One,
the weight cut issue.
There was a big issue because a general
mcclellan was huge and he was cutting a
lot of weight to get down that week
class and that was back when you know
people weren't doing it well.
They weren't rehydrating with ivs and
particularly in boxing that the weight
cutting mentality and wrestling is a
totally different mentality because you
could wrestle dehydrated and although
your performance will probably suffer,
you are not as concerned about head
trauma and the head trauma
that these guys get when they're
dehydrated is very,
very dangerous because the bleeding on
the brain is just way more devastating.
Apparently all the deaths that have ever
occurred or almost all the desks ever,
ever occurred in boxing have occurred
outside of the heavyweight division.
And the reason being that those are the
guys that are cutting the weight and the
heavyweights aren't.
But there's this one guy that got really
fucked up on hbo like I want to say a
year or two ago.
Um,
he fought that cuban kid.
Uh,
was it Eric Perez that he fought?
Is that the guy's name?
He fought.
I don't remember.
I'm not doing a good job of remembering
it,
but it was a rare instance of a
heavyweight being like really badly
concussed in a fight and having bleeding
on the brain and having to get an
operation.
He was a russian guy anyway.
Point being,
but it was pretty crazy
when they did the documentary on a
general mcclellan was,
you know,
a fun of gentleman.
Cloudinary was knocked out.
Julian jackson,
not sealing chucks.
I think it was like seven rounds maybe
knocked him out in like one or whatever.
But he sat on the second fight and the
interview afterwards,
when I fall,
either first time I had a headache for
three weeks.
I had a headache for three weeks after
fight,
you know,
there isn't a good sign,
that isn't a good side.
And all of the,
all of the documentaries of mr out
because I watched it and I thought I
remember because I just,
you know,
something sticks in your head and his
fault.
He's not mentioned.
They never mentioned that he was
apparently the,
the spot really hard and all that.
Boys from crunk.
Yeah.
No,
they don't cry jim.
Not only do they not play these to crank
that temperature up.
Yeah.
He was manual steward would crank it up
like 100 degrees in that place.
It was like a sauna.
He couldn't have no rap music,
any swearing as well.
And even believed in light.
When lennox lewis for oliver mccoll,
they made oliver mccoll were white box
in because he thought that it made him
move quicker.
Hmm.
Strange.
it's strange stuff.
Yeah.
Emmanuel steward is an interesting guy
because you so nice.
He's so personable as nice.
It was nice to know sadly,
but he was such a nice guy and when a,
when a trainer is such a nice guy like
that,
oftentimes it seems like the fighters
want to fight harder for them.
Like they want to win more.
Like they have this more of like there's
nothing worse than a fighter that has a
contentious relationship with their
trainer.
And then there's like gang,
there's some sort of animosity between
the two of them.
They leave,
they come back and you see a lot of that
and it really trips a lot of fighters up
that those contentious relationships
they have with their trainers.
He doesn't think.
I think a lot of the times though with
fires,
sometimes it may take the position of a
father figure,
you know,
or,
or an elder brother or you know,
especially a father figure because a lot
of like have come from,
you know,
not the best start in life.
You know,
it's a main site.
A lot of them come from a place with no
father in the percentage that date,
you know.
So,
you know,
I always outlie trainers.
I looked up to them and why it's a
place,
it's just,
I just think it's part and parcel of it
really.
It is and I think that's why I got like
emmanuel steward was so successful,
not just because of his deep knowledge
of boxing and his understanding of
technique,
which all were certainly there,
but also just because he was such a
great guy.
He was one when he fought thomas.
When thomas [inaudible] sugar ray
leonard.
I remember reading a manual steward and
tommy hearns lot the cells away for two
weeks and just cried.
Wow.
It's passion.
True passion house.
No,
I know.
Ring me and ring me and I was only 11.
Were there any back then?
Were there any.
Did anybody use a mental coach back
then?
Do you know of anything?
Is that when,
when did it start in combat sports?
I don't know.
I'm the only one in the world and not
saying no.
I don't know.
I just actually,
I've never heard of anyone that does it.
I know these scenes is seen sports
psychologists and stuff.
I know that steve collins,
before he fought chris,
you started going about boxing.
I love boxing.
KeeP going.
And when steve collins for chris eubank,
he came in with their phones in and now
in the ring and it played with you,
but sad because nigel bennett used to
hypnotherapists paul mckenna to go from
old to beat general mcclellan and then
you bank because he enjoyed,
uh,
Michael Watson so badly that he had.
And he saId steve collins is like,
they see.
Well no,
when he's hurt because we're getting
such a state,
he won't know when he's beat.
You know what I mean?
He was worried that was going to take
too much punishment.
Yeah.
Or whatever the whatever the game was.
But eight worked for collins.
Collins beat chris eubank twice.
We might've beat him anyway.
Might be.
It might be a voice shenanigans isn't,
uh,
it's,
um,
it's mind games.
Yeah.
It's like the,
the fragile psyche of a person that's
about to go into,
on armed combat like that.
It's really interesting because most
people would think of them as fearless,
who just the toughest motherfuckers on
the planet about to step in between
those ropes,
duke it out,
but meanwhile there's a press,
they're bouncing back and forth and
there's,
there's doubt and fear and all these
different things that are playing on
their mind.
Um,
you've seen the Mike Tyson movie,
right?
Yes.
The documentary.
That one thing that he did,
that speech where he described what it
was like to walk into the ring and what
he felt like and now he had all these
doubts until he got into the ring and
then we'd gone into the ring.
He was a god.
He hit me to used hypnotherapy.
Didn't know diddy customer always to.
I hit out in yolo show because I didn't
know I had one of your guys said,
I don't know.
He was speaking to you guys.
Remember?
I know.
I wish I could remember.
Remember,
remember latter my feet law sometimes.
But um,
yeah,
he was talking.
He said that customer,
you use it,
use it will.
Custom model was certainly one of the
first and most prominent to talk about
psychology to a fighter and it was a
main point of focus in like interviews
about tyson,
where he would talk about the things
that d'amato told him and mano in the
footage that they have of him.
You know,
there's many,
many different speeches that he gave to
tyson that we're on recording.
Yeah.
And you know the one about fire being a
friend.
Yeah.
Figures.
Like I'll tell you,
I really like,
I liked freddie roach,
of course.
Produce credit already liked coming to
pick us up,
whether it was over the moon.
It's like a little kid.
He's a very nice guy.
Very,
very,
um,
uh,
accommodating.
Well virgil hunter,
if we just want virgil hunter sets a got
metaphors which it learning stories.
He eight and he eight.
He says a lot of cool things I like
about life and about.
I think if you've got experience of life
and connect,
you can convey it in such a way that it
helps that stops more policy or I think.
Yeah,
I mean and,
and moved To,
you know,
from the female side,
the way she trained kirkland,
you know,
there's probably very few trainers as
ferocious in the world.
Is that woman.
yeah.
Some of the training that she used to
have that guy do that.
The big one,
punch knockout,
cheeky fucking bad.
she could've shot.
That was a chick that christy martin
avoided lecture was on fire get away
from me.
She didn't want to have nothing to do
with that and wolf and there's a great
video of an wolf driving a truck and
harness on the front of it with a heavy
bag hanging from,
say,
kirkland's backing up.
Doing is heavy,
bag it up.
It's fucking fat.
Anything when he fought canelo didn't
have her in the call,
but like that shock canelo he went down.
We're all,
well,
he didn'T train with her and he didn't
have her in his corner and she was
actually still managing them too.
It waS just,
the whole thing was a mess.
That's unfortunate,
but you know what canelo might have done
that to him anyway because it was a
motherfucker I'm telling he's dangerous
and is all there is a whole lot,
but he's like,
you know,
think it's prince doesn't even.
It was amazing and it back in his day
when he left blend angle,
they had a really close relationship
from seven and you know,
old irish guy and he has got loads of
still racing,
you know,
metaphors and blah blah blah.
And when he left wink a bank,
which in sheffield,
it's not far from me.
He wasn't the same.
He wasn't saying like tyson and kevin
rooney.
It just seems to have a gel.
They seemed to know another system that
works.
We'll look.
Tyson was incredible.
I felt like kevin.
Well kevin rooney was still a part of
the custom model legacy.
Yeah.
No,
he had trained under demato as well and
they kind of carried over,
but he didn't have the same relationship
with kevin rooney that he had with
custom model where it was he wanted
custom happiness.
You want a custom models?
Love,
he wanted a custom model to father
figure.
I mean really literally was,
I mean he took him in,
but again,
it comes back to what you do and what
your focus is,
where it is really about mental states,
that mental state of wanting to please
the father,
wanting to please this mentor wanting to
this person that you love and care so
much about their opinion and their,
their idea of you,
that it becomes a significant motivating
factor and that tapping into these
factors,
tapping into whatever it is that allows
you to achieve that amazing state of
success.
Well,
that's why I like to get my clients.
I like to get to noma clients in a,
in a,
in every way because then you get the
best from them.
Then there's a saying that's less than
100 percent.
Support is sAbotage,
so if you're not getting 100 percent
with them and then giving you 100
percent but never going to get what you
know,
what you can really achieve,
but it's like,
I like to really get to know them and
understand them.
Once you to client elo is going to be a
client forever,
you know,
I've got a support system where again,
as the same lit off,
colin is like,
you know,
they,
they get back to on a regular basis and
I never keep out of touch with them
because you always want them to know if
they need me,
you know,
I'm not needy,
I don't need to be needed,
but I like,
I like stating concept with them right
when I'm successful of it.
Well,
you also develop a project and you
develop a relationship with this person.
That person becomes a project.
Yeah.
And so you seem to get a great thrill
out of other people becoming successful,
which is a great quality and that's the
exact quality that you need in order to
be a mentor,
you know,
in order to be a coach in order to be
the best coaches are clearly the coach
that gets personal enjoyment,
has a real deep investment in the
student getting better.
Yeah.
I just like,
I have a lot of.
I get a lot of praise of coaches.
Mark,
mark anthony's,
mark kamora who's jealous coach.
Um,
I was talking to joel facetime and then
mark says you've done a really good job.
I,
I really like that.
I don't know,
my son,
my son will come across a bit.
Um,
I dunno gushy,
I just love it.
I really love it.
I just love the way fi is.
I like people achieving.
I like people getting out of darkness.
I know.
No,
it's like to be there.
You know what I mean?
And it's nothing more of a relief.
The not being a,
you know what I'm saying?
Just put the right direction.
See people just glow and they think you
only get that eureka moment,
the light bulb moment where they've done
something wicked or they've done
something they didn't think they could
do that for me.
Priceless.
Do you get paid for it?
Of course it's a job,
but it's priceless to me.
Priceless.
Well,
that's probably why you're drawn to it.
One,
that's why you're good at it.
And that's what you,
you kinda have to be that right in order
to be good at that job.
like the worst thing you could ever be
as a mentor is be jealous of the success
of your students.
Yeah.
Or to hope that your student doesn't do
as well,
but we've all seen,
we've all seen that from coaches.
I mean everyone's seen self sabotage
from coaches.
That's dark shit.
Yeah.
It is.
There is,
there is an element of,
there is an element of jealousy and the
or whatever in some and sergeant and
people.
It's a lot of times it's like former
competitors.
You know,
you know,
I,
I think,
I don't know if you agree with this,
but I think when a,
when a coach has been a fighter,
there's a transition from him being
still a fighter to a coach.
You know,
I've got a friend called frankie elders.
It's got a really good jimmy and women's
shelter in manchester and I see that
with him now.
He was a fighter.
Very good one.
And I can see the transition now of how
he is.
I've been a coach.
He's like all these kids that look up to
him and you know,
like a Jordan watson's coach,
Richard Smith.
He is the same and they got this sort
of,
you can see the transition because they
were fighters and then they'd be gone.
Mentors and coaches that I like watching
that.
That's interesting.
It's an interesting um,
metamorphosis.
Yeah,
it is.
And it is an important metamorphosis too
because if you always identify with
being a fighter,
you never going to be a great coach.
You have to accept this new stage of
your life and embrace it the same way
you embrace being a fighter to do it
with 100 percent of your ability and
your focus.
It's hard for some people because at the
end it becomes not about them.
It becomes about them helping other
people and some personalities and not
really suited for that.
Well,
some well fires are about them.
I mean it's know certain.
Not all of them but certain amounts of
it has to be about them because they're,
the ones are taking the risk.
They're the ones that to get in the
beats aren't me go in the ring and take
the,
take the shocks and take the,
take the pain,
you know,
the main.
So it's,
it is difficult for a person to
transition,
but that's with the change of values.
As you get older,
your values change in you,
you start to shift from volume to value.
Do you like it?
Do you have longterm goals as far as
like what you're trying to do with
mental coaching?
Um,
yeah.
I mean I would like to get into coaching
people to be mined coaches.
I want elite people.
I don't want bullshit.
I don't want that.
I want people are as passionate as me,
so we're going to be doing that in 2016.
Mccollins got a um,
a thing now.
So if anyone wants to know about,
they can get me on my website,
[inaudible] dot com or facebook or
whatever because hypnosis page under can
tell them about ace.
Got a,
a new sort of a series of videos where,
and go step by step to learn to be a
mind coach from my,
my long term goal is just to get,
just keep improving and keep getting
better myself because I love it.
Read and all the time a bottom quite
boring really.
It's going on about it to people.
Um,
my long term goal is,
well,
look how well Mike Doyle say stone
movies,
dire.
You know,
I'd like to be that.
I'd like to get that to be the,
the,
the months ago to the goto guy.
I'm not enough of a people that have the
same passion,
you know,
regardless of if it's fighting and all
people that just want to achieve or at
least get something better a little bit
further.
If not,
it's really far.
How many people do you work with it or
not?
Fighters?
Quite a lot.
Yeah,
quite a lot.
What's a common thing that they come to
you with?
Confidence.
Everything is confidence.
90 nine point nine percent of stuff.
It's confidence and just,
yeah,
confidence and people.
People come to me,
it's always the same thing.
They come In because I work from home or
to work on scale,
skype or face time and they always talk
about what they don't want that.
so first thing out of everyone's mouth
to talk about what they don't want and
we asked them what they do want.
They still talk about what they don't
want,
so you have to change the direction of
the thought pattern because they're just
so focused on sates up rock and roll,
the rock,
and you have to just move them to where
they want to go and then say,
now what you want instead of focusing on
that now where do you want to go now?
What you're doing,
what you okay,
and we deal with that and in in various
ways,
timeline therapy or hypnosis or
whatever,
and then we move them towards where they
want to go to.
So when you're dealing wiTh someone and
their issue is confidence,
what are the myths?
What are the factors?
What are like the things that are
holding people back?
Are there common factors that you find
over and over again with people that
keep them from being confident?
No shit.
Sherlock syndrome,
I call it this way.
You have to be like sherlock.
I have to like thinking holmes english
and he has to think about things.
What really is going on in there?
That's that sweet.
So cool.
That's why it's so exciting because
everyone's different and out there sort
of,
you know,
a thing that keeps them back or
whatever.
It is strange.
Everyone's different.
it's whether it'd be a past
relationship,
whether it be a,
like you said,
bullying,
whether it be parents,
whatever,
or a current relationship or a current
relationship.
Yeah.
That,
that's,
that's toxIc and they shouldn't be in
it.
I don't tell them not to because It as
ecologically it's not right ecologically
that mulhall psychological,
psychological,
not right and good for the environment.
It's not good for the environment.
Oh,
by violent language,
screaming and fighting with the message.
But um,
no,
I just think that they have to figure it
out.
And you kind of know anyway,
you,
we've met people that you think and you
shouldn't fucking bananas or bananas or
whatever.
When I was young,
I used to try to talk to help those
people are just to try it or tell them,
hey man,
you shouldn't be in that relationship.
You don't get no facts wIth to figure
that shit out for yourself.
You don't get no thanks.
So everyone's going to be mad at you.
Her,
him,
everybody.
Yeah.
So,
so,
so it's about the environment,
the environment around them is
ecological sort of in some ways.
Yeah.
And it's also many times whatever is
holding them back is also with led them
to be in that relationship,
that toxic relationship in the first
place.
Yeah.
unfortunately.
I've met people that their relationships
is really essentially like a carryover
of their mother.
And that's always so odd.
It's like I have friends who can't do
anything and unless they check in with
their wife,
they have to ask their wife for every
purchase.
They have to ask her why before,
any decision,
anything they want to do.
They can't say hey,
uh,
I want to go to the game with mike,
you know,
you can't say that.
You have to go and ask permission and
see if it's okay.
And would it be alright if.
I mean he is a people that aren't even
married but you.
But because you travel and I travel
because I know come and st infusion and
y'all college stuff you.
If you let a girl friend of mine scenes
can be in my life getting married in
august,
if you want that sort of lag,
you're going who you're with and blah,
blah,
blah.
You're not goIng to.
You're never going to eat.
It can't work.
I've had those before.
They're brutal.
Horrible.
Yeah.
It's horrible on both sides.
You know?
It's brutal.
It's brutal for the man's brutal for the
woman and it's brutal for the woman
that's asking the man where you going?
What are you doing?
What?
It's a terrible mindstate for her to be
into a smaller about them than it is
about,
you know,
it's more about then what that company
through that insecure is that I've done
that myself.
I have to not myself.
We feel that it's,
well,
it's very difficult to,
to grow inside of a relationship because
it seems like you have to have your own
shit together before you can attract
someone with their shit together.
So if you don't have your shit together,
you usually wound up with wind up with
someone who also doesn't have their shit
together and it's very difficult to,
for the two of you together to work it
out.
Yeah.
Like attracts like.
Yes.
So oftentimes people like they really do
have to break up in order to get on with
their own life.
The potential.
That was shit that they work.
Let's bring it to the next one.
And then it becomes a cyclic behavior.
It's difficult.
Well that's the weirdest one.
When you get involved with someone and
then somewhere early in the relationship
with her screaming at you and you're
like,
whoa,
whoa.
What the fuck is going on here?
Like what is this?
Is this what you do?
Let's boundaries,
isn't it?
If you've not have,
you know the on overstep the boundary
and all this technical further back and
then you end up not being used.
It is.
And it's also patterns that people fall
into because life is very confusing and
because life is very stressful and
there's a lot going on.
So they fall into these patterns of
making the same mistakes over and over
again from one relationship to the next
because there's comfort in those
patterns and you recognize it early on
because there aren't any real issues
like we've only known each other for a
short amount of time.
You already fucking screaming at me for
nothing.
Why are you screaming at me screaming at
me?
Because there's some other shit.
You've got the trapped dealt with it.
It's an unconscious behavior.
It's an unconscious reaction to a
situation that's not been resolved and
they think it's normal.
It's normal to scream because maybe they
grew up with people screaming at each
other or hitting each other or whatever.
Like,
yeah,
it was easy.
And then you tolerate it.
Then that increasingly it gets worse.
Yeah.
And it's interesting how those sort of
relationships can become.
You can drown in them.
Yeah.
You know,
both parties can drown because you just
can't get out of them and you're.
You're constantly involved in conflict
or the worst is conflict and resolution.
Conflict and resolution.
And they get trapped in thIs high of,
of making up and fighting and then
making up fighting and making it up.
And meanwhile,
you're life's going.
Yeah,
you're losing days is time.
Time is a time is something you just not
going to get back at the.
Hey,
you knoW,
regardless how rich you are.
I went to,
um,
a seminar by a lady called dolores ask
off.
No whiskey.
Who's,
um,
this is part of the thing called the
severance of light,
which is an eastern cervical belief
school.
Servants of light.
yeah.
I hate it.
Already know.
I know they state,
they say it's an easy thing.
Still fun to do with me.
I didn't name it that.
Don't play me some of the things that
she said that some of the things in the
seminar said very relevant.
You know,
she was talking about um,
so tell a story about time saying that
when she was in,
um,
he lived in jersey,
which is just south of england and they
went in 1940 something or other.
The germans were coming to invade and
she had to evacuate.
So I said,
well look,
you know,
you're not gonna,
I'm not gonna buy anything for your
birthday.
We're gonna have to use all the money to
be evacuated because it's going to go
and live in has wall,
which is near me and liverpool.
And he said,
well,
what I'll do is I'll give you a,
a bulk with paper and I'll give you a
time.
so every time you write a check he
writes that you want to be with me and
that time.
And he honored that time all the time.
So it made me think about how important
time is.
We just don't get a lot of it.
You know,
I'm 45 now,
21 yesterday,
you know,
in my eyes,
my mom died in,
when was it?
February now,
august,
last year.
Bomb.
You know,
your mom's there.
All of a sudden the garden,
they smarter in Poland and yet we get
tight,
I think.
Anyway,
it's everything.
Yeah,
hundred percent.
It's every.
It's also very difficult to stop and
take account of what's going on in your
life and try to figure out whether or
not it's serving you to the best of its
ability.
It was as If time is serving,
you have,
you are serving your own life.
If you're your,
the your focus and what you're doing,
your actions are serving your own
existence to the best of your ability or
whether or not you're trapped in
momentum because that's often the case
of people being trapped in momentum.
Could rob you of your life and you won't
even realize until it's too late.
Isn't any of that 60 year old guy on the
hill looking down at the guy's boeing
can out the window with the blanket.
I going bust it.
Can I go again?
No,
you can't.
There's no.
There's no second floor with the
diocese,
the,
you know.
Yeah.
It's just the way it is,
but it's also really hard to figure out
if you're trapped in an environment
where the people around you haven't
figured it out and there are stuck in
some patterns,
alcoholism
and cigarettes and all the bullshit
that's involved with whatever they've
got going on in their life.
Crime or drama or whatever the fuck it
is.
This environment,
this environment that you're not sure in
the patterns that you develop,
that's really hard for people to break
out of.
The patterns that they grew up in.
It is and it's.
But it's part and parcel of the job.
You can't say any more part and parcels
said got loads of time.
Five.
I did a podcast the other week and I
kept saying all the time.
Yeah,
that like is one that drives me crazy.
Like if I catch myself saying like if
you like,
I don't know,
like there's maybe like a way to like,
oh,
shut the fuck up and if I catch me,
if I killed myself over liking or
overing you knowing,
you know there's like,
you know,
it's like the worst is,
you know what I'm saying?
Like that's a rapper thing?
Yeah.
Well,
like in england you don't get rappers.
You have right screw downs,
prep poems.
You can over there daily with hip hop.
You should get them into douggie fresh.
Oh my goodness.
Okay.
Fresh and doug e fresh and not saying
big rat.
Remember roxanne?
About being on picky with.
Come on sunday.
That's good.
Good.
You know the greatest,
the greatest.
That without a doubt.
The best that ever did.
It was indeed wasn't a.
It was the motherfucker right there.
What do you want me saying?
How dare you?
Biggie,
biggie,
biggie.
Can't you see sometimes hypnotize me.
I just listened to classical music.
You don't.
Don't kick in the door waving the full
for all you heard was pumping.
No hitting.
No more.
Mr.
Why do you think I should have been a
rapper?
I think shield.
I think you were shitty mind coach.
If you really believe that maybe we
should swap.
Have you ever told someone that they
should be doing something different?
If you ever told someone,
hey man,
you need to fucking quit your job and
become a rock and roll star or anything.
No.
No,
no,
I've told people they shouldn't fight
really because they're not good at it or
because they take too much damage.
Oh,
okay.
We know that you've seen say fucking.
Well I.
Oh,
I thought about only had one fight.
I don't fight mba class and b class in
england.
You can meet to the hat.
Oh,
fun bd class.
And like not the best idea ever.
No.
say it nicely.
So you,
you told them they shouldn't fight
because they're coaches were shit?
No,
not coaches,
but yeah,
just so risk.
It's an early,
early risk.
And why would you tell them that instead
of telling them to get a better coach,
you do invest in it.
Lee.
He just pushed him in the right
direction.
So then some people just know some
people shouldn't fight and never really
get it.
Put it together.
Well you did what I do for the ufc for
it's showtime for
many other kickboxing fights.
And when you do that,
you do see people that kind of don't
have a chance.
Yeah.
You see,
you see a bunch of issues,
know whatever it is.
They're just there.
They're so far off.
Where they need to be like
crushes an must.
Tavi sometimes.
Yeah.
Nsa's contrast tv.
But like it's.
He says palm possibly.
What they did it again,
you parked.
I just did it again.
Sorry.
But like I'm like,
mismatches.
Trouble me more than almost anything.
I know.
It's one of the things that I really
like about mma as opposed to boxing is
boxing.
Guys would get tuned up,
fights start,
catch weight,
think about,
I don't get the cat's weight thing,
catch weights for mma.
It's usually because someone got a last
minute fight,
right and a short notice fight and they
don't want to cut all the weight.
Like say if a guy fights at 1:55,
like a glace and bow.
He fights at 1:55,
but he really walks around about 185 and
he cuts a lot of fucking weight and so
he has a process to cut that weight and
he has to.
It's pretty scientific.
They've got to kind of stay with that
process.
And if they don't like benson henderson,
when he fought brendan fache,
princeton henderson,
former ufc lightweight champion,
took a fight at one 70 because it was a
short notice fight,
stepped in and fought at one 70.
And the reason why I fight at one 70 is
because he.
This way you wouldn't have to cut the
weight and he really wouldn't be able to
take a short notice fight at 1:55.
It's just too hard to lose the weight.
Like they have to do it over a long
period of time.
Otherwise they're significantly
weakened.
You know,
they get down to a certain,
you know,
10,
15 pounds away and then they dehydrate
themselves.
Don't get why.
You know,
when cattell fought daniel gale weeks
ago,
why they made daniel gale lay lie
ariette cattails got the middleweight
title of one 60.
I didn't get that.
What they agreed to,
they agreed to.
It was 1:54,
right?
Something like that.
I'm just thought I didn't get it.
Strategy.
Yeah,
I understand that strategy.
And stanley said business,
but when was the days when that's what
your way he waits.
He was the champion at that would've
gillware would see walking around a
lighter weight middle bite.
I don't know if he's a big middle.
Well,
maybe kudos thinking about fighting
floyd.
And so he's working on ms dot fay
fighting lighter and lighter guys.
and it's payday right in dates,
but it's like one 60
champ at one 60.
And also there's the golovkin fight,
which is one 60 that he might be next in
line for gfi.
Have they decided,
is it going to be code?
Oh,
a canelo.
Well,
I think the big fight,
the big fight because I do think that
cuts out when mayweather.
It'll sell.
I don't think so.
No,
but I think canelo and canelo cotto was
a big,
big fight.
Converse.
He's mexican,
so he's big isn't it?
They don't lIke each other for some
strange reason.
You don't so that,
that'd be good.
So to speak the same language.
I don't get an addy.
Do you think it will all console?
It's hard to tell.
Um,
cotto certainly has taken more beatings,
you know,
a lot more weapons.
Yeah,
we hits a lot harder.
He's a scary fuck areas,
you know,
you,
you know the margarito fight I think
took a lot out of kodo.
It was a fucked up fight.
When you find out his history of,
of loading up as his raps,
it was hot.
Yes.
They fight wasn't easy.
No,
it wasn't a real heartfelt yes,
but the margarito fight was fucked.
When you find out that he most likely
loaded up his gloves with plaster,
what does this say?
Cotto canelo winter to fight glove in
november.
RighT now they haven't officially booked
it.
Ooh,
I'll see that.
Fuck yeah.
Cotto.
Canelo will be a great fighter and a
great fight.
Rather in the winter.
Fighting golovkin would be giant,
but nobody wants to fight golovkin
because only boxing fans know who
golovkin is.
Every mexican on the planet knows what
canelo is.
You know a lot of spanish fans and
boxing fans know khan.
Canelo is not ready to deal with that
left hook.
Some motherfucker,
dude,
boom.
Yeah,
he's a motherfucker.
He hits very hard,
but really for me,
it highlights my appreciation for me.
Whether it's technique,
maybe say what you want about him as a
human being.
He seems to be,
you know,
a less than favorable human being,
man.
But goddamn as a boxer,
he's magnificent.
Bull.
Admire his talent.
He's magnificent animal.
He's a magnificent.
I mean,
he's,
he's the best ever in my opinion.
I don't think he's the most exciting
ever.
I don't think he's the most fan
favorite,
but it's the art of hitting and not
getting hit.
Who the fuck is better?
you know,
like I had this conversation with max
kellerman about.
It was like sugar ray robinson is so
much better than him.
I'm like,
sugar ray robinson lost a jake lamata.
You're telling me that floyd mayweather
would lose to jake lamata I'd tell you,
you're out of your fucking mind.
I don't think jake lamata would lay a
glove on him.
I think Florida be all over the fucking
place.
He'd be slipped into the lab and slipped
into the right and popping that jab and
lead right hands and tying them up and I
just can't see him.
He's always the way that wasn't at
fault.
Hit me,
blah,
blah blah.
They always do that,
they always do that,
but I just think sugar ray took a lot
of.
He was an amazing fighter,
but it was a different era,
different mentality,
different style of fighting back then,
different knowledge database.
People knew more about the effects of
fighting.
Isn't it always will and always will.
Yeah,
definitely.
That's one of the most exciting things
about mma today is that you're seeing
these guys like these higher rodriguez.
He's young kids that are coming up 23
years of age and have so many fucking
tools.
It's like you compare them to young
people coming up 10,
15 years ago.
There's no comparison in mma.
It's a much larger jump than boxing.
We've got uninfused your life.
We've got a couple of kids called allied
mohamad your to too.
Two moroccans.
You train moroccans and they can fight
that moroccan magic.
I call it days ago,
bought her hurry up,
but us psychosis of compensating them
loads and loads of science or I could
just stay out of jail and stopped
breaking people's legs and shit.
Yeah.
You know,
he's just behaving.
Self stop being.
The reason why he's so good though is
he's a fucking psycho.
It's part of the reason why he's so
good.
He's made.
I'm not gonna say anything derogatory
about it because no might find me.
Well,
my,
the derogatory things that I'm saying
are all positive to psycho stuff is the
reason why he's so fucking good.
Yeah.
It's the most exciting kick boxer in the
world was so aggressive.
Have a look at your writer and then he
asked belied yet they don't see them.
Kickboxing is kickboxing at a higher
level now than it was 20 years ago.
much higher.
You know,
I'd say the miles,
they generally has 19.
You know,
leo says a generalized 19 yesterday.
No,
les is 18.
18,
19 only young kids.
They've had 210 fights.
Phone line,
you know,
um,
her and that was know the so nice kits,
the so nice.
But getting in them rings and they just
fight like fuck.
And then when they get out that treats
like,
hey,
look at it and hamburgers and fries and
very happy.
And you're like,
no,
I'd rather people that like celebrating
and getting drunk and all that.
That just chips.
Wow.
Keep them away from pussy.
Well,
I'm not going to sell it starts.
Yeah.
It starts with you already have this
super,
really,
really good kids.
You know,
he's just so fast and sharp and
technique and everything.
Well that's one of the things that
perturbs me.
The mondo that were disturbed me the
most about about glory.
It's like I just,
I see it,
I see the level,
like the nikki holt skins and you know,
the,
the high level of fighters got into
boxing now I think is he's doing that
every student as well or he's going into
it.
But I know he's boxed a few times now so
he might become a boxer in state a.
And I know he's still in it though and
it's not really common for a dutch
fighter to go into box.
And I will think tyrone's dabbling with
it.
Say so as well.
I'm not really.
Holland has not really got many boxes.
well,
tyron fought his last fight because it
was recovering from his broken leg.
Broken saki.
Yeah.
Which was devastating.
It's really rare to see a high level
kickboxer break his leg like that.
That was unusual.
Yeah.
But he,
um,
I remember him saying to me years ago at
showtime in brussels,
he said that he wanted to fight david.
Hey.
He said I want to fight david.
Hey,
I want to do boxing.
I will fight.
David haney said that to him.
David haye seems to me to be a really
good fighter,
but a little too small.
Yeah.
To beat a guy like,
like vladimir.
Yeah,
like the klitschkos just fucking these
giant guys.
He can't really reach them now.
You know,
now he's in a lot of them.
His next fight will be against tyron
fiori fiori from,
from england.
Who's the,
who's the funniest guy ever.
His tweets are funny and hilarious.
Makes I have a chance.
Do you think he has a chance?
I hope so.
I don't know.
What I thought was interesting about
vladimir klitschkos last fight is with
the referee was admonishing him for
holding and he was taking,
he was saying same was going to take a
point away from him for holding that
fucked this whole game up because whole
game was like,
pop that jab,
pop that right hand tie you up roughly
povetkin.
Yes.
And that was like bop bop,
jump and grab and pushes it down and
starts this whole game.
And as soon as that goes away,
then he's forced to stand with guys in
trade and exchange.
And you know,
he's been knocked out a few times.
I don't really do that against fillery
because fuel is bigger than him is
actually bigger than I am.
I hope she stays for the same area as
me,
so.
Right.
But that's just nationalism.
If you take away that objective
objectively,
do you think you can beat him?
It's not easy.
Not easY.
So that's a no.
I'll say,
I'll say no,
but he could also flooded basement.
You know,
it was the last person.
Knock him out.
Was it corey sanders?
No.
Someone knocked him out after corey
sanders.
Right?
What was his name?
I don't know.
I remember at 4:00
in the morning for no reason.
Like a black guy.
American.
Um.
Embrace.
Yes.
He knocked him out after corey,
right?
Yeah.
It seems like to knockout losses in a
row,
wasn't it?
But he just on that.
Just consummate professionals.
Well,
that's another manual stewart success
story.
Emanuel steward figured out how to get
him to box.
Right.
And you know,
probably engineered that whole style
that he's developed to this.
Just pop and grab style.
Well,
none of.
None of manuals.
Students with the left hook as well.
Haley.
It was all long job,
right?
Ons,
you know,
like hearns.
It wasn't really like big left hook is.
And what about mccallum?
Didn't mccallum fight under a manual?
Mike mcconnell in the body.
Snatcher maybe famous left hook to
Donald Curry.
Left to the body.
And the left upstairs was he.
Was he just do it that I believe he was
a drunk guy.
I believe mccowen because he's a video.
There's a video of um,
inspiring with mcclellan.
Oh,
that's just the nice classic.
This live.
It's so,
so amazing to watch cheese,
isn't it?
It really is an art,
but it's also an art with a very short
amount of time.
You could pursue it and the very limited
number of times you can get hit,
you know,
and I think I got to show as a shallow
existence.
That's one thing that used to disturb me
most about mma gyms maybe say 10,
15 years ago.
These guys really didn't have a.
There was a shouldn't say these guys.
Some gems really didn't have the best,
most
tactical striking coaches that had a
deep knowledge and understanding of
striking.
So these guys would be beating the fuck
out of each other,
just like the throwing bombs at each
other in the gym and you would watch it
and they weren't working on technique.
They weren't working,
they weren't sparring to get better at
the art of hitting and not getting hit.
They were just wailing on each other.
Yeah.
And you know,
that was toughening them up in quotes,
air quotes,
and then they would go into the gym or
go into the ring and fight and they were
carrying all the damage that they were
accumulating in the sparring sessions.
And a lot of these guys now are kind of
speaking up like jamie varner,
who's a former wec champion,
a top lightweight contender in the ufc
just recently retired.
And he's talking about the amount of
sparring that he did and how fucked up
it was.
Also,
he was sparring with much larger guys
who was sparring with ryan bader have
fights at two.
Oh five.
And he's fighting at 55.
And bRian baiters class at two.
Oh five.
So he's fighting a guy 50 fucking pounds
heavier than him.
He sparring.
I'm in The gym is madness.
It's still Texas wedding.
Sad,
doesn't it?
Fuck you in the kitchen studies debut
last year.
Say that I think it was in Brazil,
was that.
I know.
Anyway,
dot ringtail from ace from just the
same.
It relates to on the same road as made
lives in Brazil.
Now darren,
tell east goodman a south by is very,
very good kid as what child for him,
there's a lot of good talent.
Now.
this is an amazing time for mma.
I mean this is such a.
It's such a young and blossoming sport.
There's the level of striking is slowly
and steadily getting faster and faster
and better and better.
It's so.
It's really an amazing thing to watch.
The jujitsu is getting better.
Everything's getting better.
There's no comparison whatsoever.
I mean,
I don't know what the difference between
1993 kickboxing was.
I mean I know there's,
if you watch like andy hook or mike
bernardo,
there were very good,
but they're probably not as good as badr
hari.
Right?
But the difference between say fighters
from ufc one and fighters today,
I mean you're talking about a massive
evolution like generations of evolution,
like a thousand years of growth,
sort of amazing.
It was no comparison whatsoever.
It's going to scan it all,
letting very quickly from mistakes.
So what people have done Before learning
very quickly and also accumulating the
techniques from other disciplines,
because a lot of the guys who started
out,
they're really only good at one thing.
Either they're really good at striking
or they're really good at grappling.
That was basically it.
But you're getting these guys today that
are great at everything and that's just
a small complaint isn't a complete.
It was fragmented,
wasn't an first ufc started.
It was fragmented with people at a jiu
jitsu and male smith was it was he pat
smith best ones and he was the one dutch
guy.
Which guy?
Blind alando v or whether it be books in
lifetime.
Twice.
He was just on all the dunks and yeah,
he was dangerous.
Same traIners.
Ramon decker called calamities with
glory.
Now he's the matchmaker for glory.
He.
He trained him.
Yeah.
He was an interesting guy.
Early on in the beginning were very
good.
Thai boxer,
but a good example,
the guy who didn't know how to grapple
and he would get take down to the ground
and just smashed he in.
They got beat by a dutch kid,
wasn't it?
The elbow wasn't.
Yeah,
goddammit.
Rem co pardue.
Yeah.
Rem co got hIm in a headlock,
took him to the ground and just blasted
his brains out with elbows.
I mean he elbowed him like four or five
times.
Guy got chills mixed.
That was an important fight for people
to realize that ninjitsu is bullshit.
A lot of people really believed they
were going to karate chops on people.
Yeah.
The,
the level in compare.
Well,
that's also one of the reasons why
performance enhancing drugs are so
prevalent in mma.
It's because there's so many different
things that you have to work on.
Like if you're a boxer,
okay,
what do you have to do if you do your
road work and then you're gonna do your
boxing work.
You know,
you do your sparring or your pad work.
I mean,
that's what you do.
Spar x amounT of days per week.
The other days you're,
you're hitting pads,
work in the bag and doing your
combinationS,
but you're only working on one skill an
mma.
You're not even just working on boxing
when it comes to striking you gotta
train elbows,
you gotta train kicks,
you gotta train knees.
You've got to train a different stance
because you're worried about being taken
down,
so you have to work on your sprawl.
You have to work on.
You take down defenSe under hooks,
wizard,
step away from the cage.
How to get back up.
Then you have to work on your jujitsu,
you have to work on sweeps,
you have to work on actual submissions
and you have to figure out like what,
what,
how much can I do like,
yeah,
and you have to get fat as well.
Exactly.
You see a guy like cain velasquez,
you never see tHat guy attempt to
submission,
never attempted to submission and all of
those ufc fights because it's the only
so much shit you can do.
So he takes guys down.
He just beats him up,
you know,
instead of trying to like,
learn all the chokes and all the.
I mean,
I'm sure he probably knows them,
but applying them in an actual fight
situation,
it's almost like there's too much to
learn.
And so when I went to,
when ncfc,
when russ pearson fault columella at,
then I realized how dangerous these guys
now I thought,
shit,
I can just kick.
He can get you on the floor.
Right?
You know,
not topic now is don't kill me.
Yes.
Basically don't break my arm.
Dope.
Right?
My leg don't kill.
That's very um,
macy's reality isn't real.
It's real kumbaya,
isn't it?
It certainly is.
Yeah.
And that's one of the reasons why mma is
become so popular is because it's so
difficult to go from that to like floyd
mayweather versus pack.
Yeah.
Or it's not much happened.
It was like a lot of movie,
which I loved.
I loved that fight.
But the,
the reality of the variables,
like the different variables that exist
in mma where god can take you down and
garden,
kick your legs so I can do so many
different things to you.
Can't just stand in front of him and
shoulder roll and box and then clench.
Just so much more going on.
The clench is just the beginning.
I'm going to press the up against the
cage and the pull your ankles out from
andrea.
They're going to mount you,
elbow you the face going to cut you
open.
It's going to be a lot going on.
It's not nearly as simple to defend
yourself as it is in a boxing ring.
hey straight.
Because I mean it's just like looking at
the most.
They deserve the belt to get the belt,
the ufc belt.
He must deserve it.
Stuff.
They have to go for it to get that to,
you know,
to get where they want to get together.
Once a gaze.
Ridiculous.
Well there's just the beat the fucking
murderers row you have to go through to
get to any shot at the title.
It's like the guys you have to go
through today.
Anybody that's fighting for a title
today,
like fuck man,
you gotta earn that just goddamn massive
group of contenders in every way class
that are dangerous shit.
The way got the right mindset.
Yeah.
You've got the right mindset.
Do you anticipate that this mental
training thing is going to be a part of
every fighter's camp in the future?
do you think it should be okay?
I think it should be because you can
get,
you know,
it can be in shape.
ThEy can,
you know,
the strength and conditioning the right
day and then if their ads are not right,
the body didn't perform.
Now what about applying that to kids?
What about applying that to kids in
school?
Not fighters,
just people in,
in school.
Um,
especially in high school or in college
where you're about to go out into the
world and so much of your success or
failure is predicated on your attitude,
your mindset,
and how your,
how your brain is organized and
inflammation.
Yeah.
I think.
I think a lot of it is just,
it's not really.
It should be.
There's so much stuff that you can do
that that's,
that can help people learn and take in
information differently than just the
cliche.
Read that.
That's what you gotta do.
You know what I mean?
Is.
But it's that many phase.
So that's why it's so interesting
because these people are so many
different types of people,
siemens ways of thinking,
you know,
like we did earlier.
We did the larger member.
Why?
We want to explain what that is.
How come I always,
I'm a slight self-induced.
All hypnosis is self induced haka.
We say self-induced hypnosis thing where
you,
you basically,
you find a spot on the wall that's
higher than your eyeline.
So you'd imagine that you're looking
through your middle of your eyebrows and
what you do is you focus on a spot on
the wall,
um,
and you just allow yourself to just
imagine that you can see all the way to
the left and all the way to the right.
You can imagine,
you can see really high above self and
below yourself.
And then you can imagine that you can
see 360 degrees.
And what it does,
it opens your periphery,
opens your peripheral vision,
so it gives you a slight hypnotic state
and it's a slight,
a more feeling of wellness in a way,
you know,
how relaxing,
what that feeling.
And what we did was,
you were,
you were telling me to concentrate on
that spot and then visualize magnet.
Yeah,
that was,
that was different what,
um,
what we did was we did hakalau first to,
to kind of lead you into a hypnotic
state,
um,
to,
to get you to cause you know,
you know,
you don't go,
you say these things on these rapid
inductions.
And I went on a course of rapid
inductions were,
and what does that robert inductions as
a color snap induction.
So what they do is,
if it's a slight,
you put,
um,
it's like a shock shock.
The system shock them and then they,
then you go sleep or whatever and it
puts them under very quickly.
You see it can see it on youtube and all
sorts of adult.
I can do them.
I'm a very showy techniques as well.
Um,
but I don't really dig them.
How does it work,
like shocked induction,
your sleep because your mind needs
information,
your mind needs you,
your unconscious needs information
so you can like.
There's one way you shake hands with
someone so when they go to shake your
hand that your hand,
you break the pattern and make them look
at their own hand and then you say,
look at me,
look at that.
Focus on that is a confusion technique
and then you say just focus on your hand
or that government had sleep on nigga
wonder just like that.
Yes sir.
Why or why do they go under?
Why don't they go,
what the fuck you doing in my hand,
man?
Well there is always that possibility.
Hand smelt it.
What?
I've seen it done,
I have done it.
I'm with people,
but it's all I've done it when I've been
in therapy with the client already
because I'm sulking hypnotic language in
and do various things and stuff and just
maneuver them into that state.
So I really,
you see people walking up on the street
and these cheap hypnosis and all up,
which is street hypnosis is a few guys
that do street didn't know.
She's a very good.
Vince lynch is very good.
Did
he do it like was doing in the street in
vegas?
He was making people's hand stick to
walls and why?
It's really.
Yeah.
I don't see god and it's,
it's.
Have you ever seen it?
No.
Oh yeah,
they do it.
Yeah.
It's this street hypnosis.
I've seen street magic.
He's not street hypnosis,
huh?
Yeah.
So they make people forget their names
or removed the number four.
So they go one,
two,
three,
five,
six,
seven,
eight,
nine slash 11.
But uh,
it's fun to watch,
but I know there wasn't an interest to
you because what you're trying to do is
improve people or help them live their
lives.
It looks stupid.
Know?
Well,
when I was a kid,
when I was first starting out doing
standup,
there was a guy in Rhode Island named
Frank Santos and he was an r rated
hypnotists.
And up untIl that point,
I thought hypnosis is bullshit
until I saw this guy over and over
again,
many,
many times.
He had a night once a week at stitches
comedy club in boston.
So I saw him dozens and dozens of times
and he would hypnotize giant and he knew
when people were under and when they
were bullshitting,
he would get guys who would look at them
and you go,
no,
you're not mean,
this is not working.
You're faking it.
Come on.
And he would take them off the stage.
He knew when people are under a new,
when they weren't.
But he could get a whole group of people
maybe like bring 10 people on stage and
by the time he's done hypnotized them,
six or seven of them would be totally
under.
And he'd have them doing all kinds of
ridiculous things.
Like they thought they were having sex.
They would come in their pants like,
like really amazing.
I mean I know for you you're thinking
like,
this isn't helping anyone.
What he wasn't trying to do that he was
trying to put on a show.
It was,
you know,
people pay to see it.
It was funny
pay to see it and they want to go on
stage freewill.
Um,
I've done it before we part and parcel
of
part and parcel of,
of itch.
Is that coffee,
coffee,
coffee.
Well anyway,
sorry,
don't worry about that.
So I don't,
I don't think that it just doesn't do
anything,
but how are they doing that?
Um,
because it's,
they,
if you go to a hypnotherapist and they
say you can hypnotize me brand fuck off,
what did you come fall right now?
What's the point?
you know,
you've got a piece or to buy a pizza,
you know what comes here.
He comes,
get hypnotized,
you know,
half go along with it anyway,
and,
and it,
and it helps.
If the client's got an issue they want
to change,
then the more likely to change if they
want to change with you,
you know,
um,
but the,
the people that do on the stage,
they just,
they want it to happen sooner than they
don't mind looking daft.
So that's cool.
But why did with you is we did the
modern as well,
which was just logistically stood way
because we did the peripheral vision and
then we just imagined that there was a
magnet that could say negative energy
from your body and what that does is you
use your own imagination to take that
negative energy out.
You do move is because it a weird
still for what is happening there
really,
because obviously there's no magnet and
your mind thinking that negative energy
is being pulled out of your body.
Is that just an adjustment of your
attitude or an adjustment of your
perceptions knows?
Who knows?
Who knows,
but it will.
Alls I know is it works very,
very well on east relaxing and
is that related at all to what Frank
Santos used to do by getting an entire
group of people think that they were
doing wacky shit in front of an audience
because it's.
Yeah,
it's the installation of what is the
installation that's different.
You know,
there was no matter she sat and not
having sex.
It's an installation and it's
right.
But I didn't really think that there was
a thing.
Yeah,
yeah,
I know.
Of course they don't,
they don't.
They go on there for that experienced or
thankful for the experience,
but it sort of respected where they
believe there's is the end result if you
feel more relaxed.
Right.
It's almost like a placebo effect.
Right?
Yeah.
So the placebo effect or the mind
perceiving this change and then
adjusting your attitude accordingly.
Yeah.
That,
that's what it is.
He says just a redirection of thought,
redirection of focus.
But that was different than the hypnosis
part because the hypnosis part,
when you hypnotized me,
like I was definitely hypnotized.
Like I definitely could see.
I could listen to your voice and I knew
that I was hearing your voice,
but I was in this weird sort of dream
state.
Yeah,
I was aware of it,
but not aware of it.
Yeah,
like if you took my pants off,
we'd have a problem.
I would be,
I would have woke up.
And what the fuck's this guy trying to
pull?
But you know what I'm saying?
Like he's trying to pull you out.
It wasn't true,
but I wasn't,
uh,
I wasn't eating it.
It's a weird state because you're not,
you're not totally there,
but you're kind of there.
Is that a good way of describing it?
Yeah.
But you still dry.
You're not gonna do anything that's
against your values anyway.
Really.
But you're going to do anything.
Yeah.
Well like,
but wouldn't anyway because I'm not like
that.
I'm not like that as a hypnotherapist or
as a mind coach.
And um,
what we did with you is we,
uh,
we,
we got you to focus on your thumb.
That film didn't say your thumb,
thumbs.
He disassociate yourself.
Instead of saying your thumb thumb,
we focus on that film and then you just
get your focus on that.
And then there was a structure like a,
as you want to free yourself for.
It's for,
it's called to do that one,
two,
three,
four.
You know,
see,
see it just like counting down as well.
No,
do you account we know but using
numbers,
you know,
bright say so cause assault of,
focusing on that.
If you're focusing on that then your
unconscious mind.
So you folks in that not,
and I'm talking to you with language
that,
that your unconscious mind recognize it
to be relaxing.
Are you aware of all at all rather have,
um,
like the concept of like a manchurian
candidate?
Yeah.
What do you think about that?
Um,
have you ever watched derren brown,
derren brown hypnotist,
brown?
Yeah.
He's,
yeah,
he's a,
he's an entertainer.
He's a magician as well,
but he's fantastic.
And he did one called the experiments
that you can watch them on youtube.
And he did one where they shot Stephen
Fry.
Stephen fry is like a,
uh,
english,
a comedian guy and a very posh,
very,
very intelligent guy,
member of mensa herbal,
super smart.
And they,
uh,
he got this certain guy,
they did a lot of,
uh,
elimination techniques,
you know,
to see what was most susceptible and
they use a certain guy to go and shoot
Stephen Fry.
No,
not with a real gun obviouSly,
but just whether,
I don't know.
It's interesting.
There's a case where I,
uh,
what he assassinated,
someone who needs said definitely I was
under hypnosis and everybody's just
saying that while he's in prison,
don't know,
you know.
Wow.
So do you think it's possible?
Um,
we,
you,
you would know,
right?
Probably more than 99 percent of the
people on the planet.
I think if it's against your deep level
of value,
you won't do it.
But what if you're fairly shady but
innocent?
Oh,
that's darkness.
That's very right.
I mean,
if you find a guy who's not maybe never
killed anybody,
but maybe he's done a few fucked up
things and you can talk back guy and
doing something like that through
hypnosis.
Possibly.
Maybe because you're essentially
steering someone towards a crime that
they ordinarily would have avoided.
What did you say the,
it's again on youtube,
uh,
italian.
A hypnotist and took money off the
cashier.
She got just took money out of the
register.
No,
still not derren brown played on
television.
No,
he did it.
It was captured on cctv camera.
Oh,
so it was a thief.
Yes.
And they were,
there was one where devin brown paid
with paper,
so what it did is it got gets paper,
which is the same as like dollar bills
that's just blank paper and he said
there's a confusion technique,
so he said,
don't quote me on this,
on the script,
but you sat down and I just moved into
the town,
I just got off the train and I don't
know whether to go with that way or that
way because my friend said you have to
get the terrain but don't know where to
go that way or that way or that way.
But do you know where the station is?
But he said,
get the tanks.
Just take it,
it's fine.
And then when he's,
when he's said said,
just take it,
it's fine.
So confused as the people say that way
or that way.
So just mixed directing your thoughts.
He's moving his hands everywhere.
She thinking,
what's this guy on about?
Then he's saying take it,
it's fine.
So when he's giving them money,
he's like,
look.
He sAid,
oh,
can I buy that?
And he just gives them paper and that,
that's still confused,
not for long because they assume
comradery,
but it confuses them to st.
Take it.
It's fine.
So these.
I've worked at a,
um,
like an ice cream place when I was a
kid,
sort of ice cream and hamburgers was
supposed called newport creamery.
And I remember they had someone came in
and they called a flim flam artist or
someone would come in and they'll give
you $20 and they'd say,
can you give me,
um,
a 10,
a five and five ones?
And then they would say,
okay,
actually can you give me a 10,
five,
five ones and four quarters,
no,
you know,
what,
give me two tens.
And then they would start to tens of
five and four quarters now.
And then all of a sudden you,
you'd have More than $20 that you'd be
giving them for their them.
and the manager closed the,
uh,
the register.
They went,
hold on a second,
what is going on here?
And they shut the register and they had
like this sort of weird eye to eye
moment with this guy who was trying to
hustle this kid that was working the
cash register.
It was,
it was really fascinating.
It was like a guy
who was a con man.
And I remember I was,
um,
I was near it.
I wasn't involved in leo wasn't,
I wasn't working on the cash register,
but I was close to it.
Forget what I was doing,
but I remember watching this going,
what's going on?
What is something happening here?
And then they had like a little meeting.
They explained when you're working the
cash register,
you have to be careful.
People that start asking you for weird
things,
asking you to,
you know,
because they start twisting your brain
and confusing you and your memory gets
all fucked up and you're trying to
memorize what they're asking for.
And before you know it,
you've given someone $30 for $20.
Yeah.
At that,
someone did the Iowa.
It's a health club quite a few years
ago.
And I'm like,
I came in and he went,
it's frankin.
It was the owner.
I said no.
He said all his chain for his wife and
mentioned his wife's name.
Uh,
okay.
It's 20 quid.
So I went,
alright,
give them 20 quid.
That was it.
How many walks out and then front
combines,
you know,
paid for that repair of that bracelet
and what you donate.
He'd come in a talk to someone at the
battery bones.
He works at isa bond.
Your front was from shorter?
no,
frank,
what's his wife's name?
Whatever her name was.
And then they said the reception is the
money.
Anything else?
You know,
it was done.
So mesa,
they.
So he gave you like a shitty change?
Yeah,
but I just went over and gave him 20.
You know,
that's.
Yeah,
that's a weird hustle,
that hustle of trying to confuse people,
but there must be patterns that they try
to tap into and the way people recognize
money or the way people count things as
they try to disrupt and cars
numbers,
words,
especially words that can confuse people
and send them off guard or we did a
thing when we did the masters were
neurolinguistic programming and we did a
thing called quantum linguistics,
which is really interesting.
It's really cool.
Makes you laugh because it's just makes
it doesn't make no sense and one of the
best language patterns I was saying.
I always,
when I was,
when I was younger,
I was always self sabotaging.
I said,
hell,
we sell sabotage,
and a guy called chris mannix did my
masters with and I said as much and
there's a wasp nest and I've got a
stick.
Don't go near it because you'll get
stung,
but because it was your.
I always thought,
fuck.
anyway,
he'll get stoned and just see what
happens.
I'll fight.
He's stupid.
A young read after anya and he said,
what wouldn't happen if it pretended not
to do it?
So when you said what wouldn't happen if
you pretended not to do it right?
And I was like whoa.
And it just makes sense.
Nobody sends your mind in it,
especially when you did not.
so that wouldn't happen if we pretended
not to do it.
So if you pretend not to do it.
So if you're pretending not to do what
you're doing,
but what wouldn't happen?
Well you wouldn't get stuck.
It doesn't happen as you wouldn't get
stung.
Yeah.
But what,
what tended not to do it.
That's the sort of stone thing in that
it's like what would not need
to learn how to talk better?
Motherfucker.
You're talking crazy in that situation
where you,
when you,
when it's dropped on,
you know,
don't knock on top on the shoulder and
say,
well we'll never be done in the cliche
therapy thing and the therapy situation
and it's when it's put into its glided
and with language works so smoothly.
Do you pay attention at all to cults?
Do you pay attention to it?
Because I'm fascinated by people's
ability to control people,
other people's minds,
behavior.
And I always wondered whether or not
like when you see like these,
you've seen the scientology documentary
going clear.
I've started watching it.
I started watching.
It's fucking fascinating,
man.
I've,
I've watched it three times.
I can't look away.
I might watch it again.
Watch it.
It's fucking crazy.
I love to watch it.
It.
Well,
I had experience.
I have,
I've known several people that were
scientologists but one of them was one
of my neighbors and uh,
you know,
he and I had some weird exchange about,
his wife was going clear,
so I needed $50,000.
I want 50 fucking grand.
Like whoa,
what's going on?
There was like,
they're gonna do some ceremony and his
wife will no longer be influenced by
outside pressure or outside thoughts or
any anybody's criticisms or negativity
should no longer.
They're no longer affect her.
And they needed 50 grand for that.
And also what the fight.
But he fucking look in his eye.
He was telling me like oranges have
vitamin c in them,
you know,
for him it was like pretty
straightforward obviously.
And I've always been fascinated like
what the fuck is going on with my friend
named aiden perez?
He was into scientology.
I'm not really still is.
I don't think he is.
But he went to pflag,
whIch is the base,
the base where that at the scientologist
half the main place,
what they have.
And tom cruise's sister is named ada.
Sorry,
tom cruise's sister's child is named
aiden after him.
Whoa.
So he was into it.
I went to it.
I went to a couple of times years and
years ago and then I creep me out of it.
But I don't know if whatever floats your
boat,
if it's not causing you any,
but I haven't seen that government class
out welding.
So say I agree with that as well.
If it's not hurting you and what do I
give a fuck?
I agree with that as well.
Until you start watching these
documentaries,
you go,
well clearly it's hurting some people.
It's definitely hurting people.
It's breaking up families.
It's,
it's,
it's really fucked up the way they
attack some people that,
that dissent or that leave or do.
I mean,
if the people that are on the show,
the documentary that are telling if
they're telling the truth and that's
debatable,
you know,
uh,
own the only thing.
No,
and the people that they're talking
about,
no,
there's some mind control going on
there.
There's some,
there's some absolute definite mind
control going on there.
And I wonder,
is that related in any way to hypnosis?
The,
the
ability to these people have to
manipulate these folks into the hitler
speech,
mind camp,
right?
Hitler did,
you know,
some people maybe a search of for
something to be influenced you not so
main sewings always going to be a lot
easier,
you know,
so I was going to be that I was going to
be susceptible people.
There is always going to be susceptible
people,
but his cult like when you see like a
jim jones speech or you know,
when,
when someone is giving some sort of a
cultish speech,
is that similar in some ways to
resonate?
It doesn't resonate with,
with the,
with the person,
with the paypal.
Um,
I won't say hypnosis,
but you'll say us to resonate with what
they believe in and you know,
they,
they take floats the boat of gas,
you know what I mean?
It could again latch on.
So it's like cold,
cold,
cold reading,
psychics,
you know,
say stuff like I'm cold reading and
halting by no means a different script.
Still trying to think,
talking about how it's different
readings different.
I went to a couple of years ago was,
you know,
it was roads in Greece.
Anyway,
I digress.
And um,
we went over and we got stung by the
time share people and they deal anyway,
no one was going on and on to me and she
said,
uh,
what do you do in english?
And I'm a psychic psychic.
Oh,
right.
I said,
you ought to know you had an accident
near walter,
a scam maybe before he was 10.
I'm getting 10 for some reason.
While he was 10,
she went,
yeah,
you're right.
You're right.
Yeah,
he did.
He got a scar on one of your knees?
Yeah,
I've got a scar on my left knee.
I thought.
Yeah,
I thought you did.
Do you know what I mean?
And you know,
you've been really,
you've been,
you've had some,
you know,
you've got some limelight,
but you don't mind other people and
you've asked a lot of close friends.
You've got,
you've got a lot of friends.
we've only got a certain amount of
clothes ones,
so everyone resonates with that.
Like horoscopes.
Everyone saw like clings onto that and
you know,
this is all sorts of psychics and people
say,
oh wow,
they knew this crazy.
Yeah.
I have a friend who believes that
easily.
He went to somebody.
He's like,
man,
they told me all about my grandmother.
I'm like,
bitch,
don't you know about your grandmother
telling you some shit you already know.
Kind of psychic is that it doesn't make
any sense and I never understood it
until we had this guy.
do you know who bannon check is?
Yes.
A headband check on the scifi show,
joe rogan questions,
everything.
He was brilliant and stunning and scary.
It was scary how good he is at,
but also super honest.
He said,
I'll Tell you right now,
I don't.
I'm not a psychic,
I don't have any psychic ability at all.
This is all bullshit and I hate when
people steal from people and rob them.
What I'm doing is entertainment and it's
a show and I have very specific
techniques that I use to achieve this.
Yeah,
that's why I don't.
I can't think of anything else.
That's why I can't.
That's why I don't fuck
around when hypnosis and do this.
No,
no,
no.
Well,
he was not the game is it?
He wasn't doing hypnosis.
He was just pretending to be able to
read your mind and be able to put it.
It was all,
but he was really,
really clear about it.
Saying,
these are just techniques.
I am not really seeing anything that
other people can't see.
I don't have any special ability,
but the people that do claim that like,
god,
I don't know how it is in england,
but in California in particular,
you'll drive down the street and you'll
see I'll say four or five of these
fucking psychic readings kind of baptism
that there's loads of chiropractors as
well as low.
It's an american chiropractic bullshit.
Is that what you're saying?
Is the chiropractors,
and I see that tarot and driving on the
street and counterparts,
they don't see that many in england.
A lot of people think chiropractors are
bullshit too.
Like a lot of reputable people think
it's bullshit,
but just moving your neck around and
it's like click and killed.
Yeah,
across a lot of money to go to 150 bucks
and then just getting twisted around pop
in your back.
But then some people say like there's
certain things that chiropractors do
that really are beneficial.
So the fuck.
Do you believe?
The ones I've.
I've been to a couple of times.
They would have been here.
They've been god's fellow right
afterwards where there's this one guy
that used to work with a lot of fighters
and he was what they call a zone healer
and his idea was that he was like sort
of tricking your body into healing
because he was sort of using the placebo
effect,
telling you that he was healing you by
popping your neck or moving your body in
a certain way.
But he really wasn't doing anything
other than shit of normal chiropractor.
I don't know.
Try not to pay attention to that shit.
That stuff drives me nuts because it's
deception and whether or not it's
effective or not is debatable because it
deception can be effective.
Right.
And isn't that sort of part of what,
you know,
what the placebo effects,
this is what I'm against in the next
thing really is the point was trying to
make it.
I don't fuck around with people,
you know,
they come here for help.
The genuinely want your help.
You genuinely wants to get where they
want to get to heaven.
You can't fuck around with people.
Right.
It's not fair.
They pay.
Yeah.
They looking for you to help them out.
I both effect because then the chief
something together,
you know,
it's good.
I like that there's a lot of these of
shit and everything that went through
there is more shocking shafts and good
ones.
You know what I mean?
And isn't that.
It was also a lot.
There's a lot of manipulation and a lot
of charlatans and so almost every line
of work.
Right.
But isn't that,
it's sort of relative to what we're
talking about.
It's like what is your focus like?
What are you trying to achieve?
What are you trying to achieve as a
coach,
as a coach,
you're trying to help people and make
them better.
What are you trying to achieve as
whatever you're doing as a salesperson?
Are you trying to sell people something
that's an actual great product,
like a really nice car,
like this is a car.
If you enjoy cars,
you will enjoy this car is great.
Or are you selling them a fucking shit
box?
it's been taped together and it's going
to fall apart the moment they get it out
of the driveway.
You know,
what is your ultimate goal?
You're trying to help people.
You're trying to have a beneficial
mutually agreeable relationship or
you're trying to read their poem and get
money out of their fucking with them on.
I amazing fucking amazing.
Like I never,
you know that success at joe's hot show
shelling and the success that many of my
clients have had.
I don't go.
It was me know because it's all about
the client.
They do it,
I liked the,
I liked winning and of course there's
some sort of pat on the back for myself
by me,
but I don't run around like I amazing
tile back.
Or is it just an appreciation for the
method,
appreciation of the method and
appreciate,
you know,
it doesn't stop shocking me how well it
works at times,
you know,
above 99 point nine percent of the time.
It's just a shock.
Even now.
Even now that I've been involved in it
eight years now,
he's just,
I don't know,
it's just that light bulb goes off that
you can sell.
It pulls off and stopped around.
AbouT how many years have you been doing
it full time,
full time eight?
No,
I'm half and half,
but training as well.
Training fighters.
I was,
and then I was trying to fight as it got
kind of bored of it.
I was at the chief what I wanted to
fight as it reached a level and I was
getting bored and I wasn't giving him
the attention I should do,
so I decided to stop that and then I had
a regular job anyway.
And then then I just started to get my
coaching and word of mouth,
like you got to know me through word of
mouth and then it just spread from there
and,
and it continues to do so still come and
say no,
I still come and say it as well.
I'll come and say for infusion and from
yoko,
a moitai shells and smash moy tai as
well as in england.
She's good shows and I still do de gea
at gfc and you know,
different things like that.
But I still call and say it a lot for
your car when infusion and it's much
more so I just do that as well.
But I just,
I got a lot of clients from America now.
I'm gonna put stupid o'clock in the
morning on skype,
but it's great.
Yeah.
Was there an eight hour,
10 hour difference trina?
I genuinely bills that.
I love the.
I like it.
Well that's great.
I mean that's really what life is all
about.
Finding something that you really enjoy
that you get that buzz off of and
pursuing that.
And if You can make a living like an
assignment.
And he can tell you animated by what you
do.
Well,
I'm lucky that I found a bunch of
different things that I really enjoyed
doing.
It just like this,
that you could as well.
Well there.
How about this?
The ability or the opportunity rather to
have a conversation like this regard.
like you sit down for hours totally
uninterrupted.
It's very rare to get this.
It's almost like the only way to get
these kinds of conversations is to have
this kind of conversation where,
you know,
it's being broadcast because otherwise
we'd be checking our phone.
Would it be talking,
you know,
do you want a beer?
Do you want to do this nadar this
fucking guy is annoying and this thing
is happening to me and I got a part and
parcel with that.
You wouldn't,
you probably wouldn't do that.
But you know what I mean,
like this is this.
The only way you have these intense one
on one conversations is in a podcast
form.
So in a lot of ways this podcast has
been incredibly educational.
It's been like a,
like a,
almost like a very varied university
course on a bunch of different
disciplines and interests.
I appreciate it.
It's like,
you know,
you said about Mike Mccullough and the
left hook and alIgned,
you know,
and I went,
oh yeah,
I forgot about him and like I'm not
egotistical enough to think I know
everything,
you know,
don't I seen,
like I said,
a rapid induction course and the guy was
just like,
he was doing this hypnosis gun,
he's going to sleep and this other guy
was good.
Right?
but isn't that similar like that fucking
those bullshit kung fu guys.
They're like,
students fall to the ground.
I can do.
Don't you think that's.
Is that hypnosis to what is going on
with that?
It is bullshit,
but is it just happening with the
student cause this break the students
though they're falling to the ground and
switching to a.
everybody's just daft out.
They are,
they are they under the hypnosis power
of suggestion that maybe it's a
suggestion?
Well,
maybe it's just the,
all of that.
These.
There is a lot of way at people about
how idiots and you went to state in the
middle of change.
The trajectory of the rocket that would
have got me in trouble.
That is the problem,
right?
Like some people have big noses and some
people are idiots.
Some people got gray and some people.
Yeah.
It's like the genetics very.
There's not everybody could be einstein.
No,
no,
no.
Some people you go high and they follow
the ground.
I've,
I've seen some videos of fake kung fu
and it's fucking amazing.
Like there's this one dude and he was
teaching this class and he had this,
this girl and he was moving her back and
forth and back and forth like,
like,
like a comedy.
Like it was a comedy but it was real
and,
and he,
you know,
he'd make her dance and shock her and
then she would fall to the ground and
she was one.
Now that guY gets his students like a
big bellied guy gay on.
And then she does this,
gave him an oscar.
That was a right performance.
And seniors like flops on the deck and
he's our flu.
Indiana was propofol naming because I'm
here at the moment in America.
We,
Jordan Watson,
who's a,
like super tight and we was watching it.
He was pacing ourselves often is
phoning.
Well,
there's a lot of that out there,
man.
There's a lot of that fake kung fu stuff
out there.
Less and less now than there was in 1993
when the ufc came along.
That's one of the things that the ufc
has done that's amazing,
is eradicate a of the bullshit martial
arts.
There's a lot of fake practitioners out
there.
And you know,
eddie bravo has this hilarious story of
this fake kung fu teacher that he was
taking lessons under.
you know,
he's a young kid.
He didn't know any better.
And uh,
the guy was going to China to study
under his master and he rang,
eddy,
ran into them at the supermarket when
the guy was supposed to be in China to
fuck.
And they didn't realize that isn't
taking conch food.
Just making shit up.
Like everything he was doing was just
totally made up.
Karate chop of people on top of the head
and saying you'd kill them if you hit
them correctly,
but it's that,
that sort of make dojo type fake martial
arts stuff was really,
really,
really prevalent a few decades ago if I
grew up with drunken master there and
all of them in all the,
uh,
run run,
shaw,
mavis,
you know,
golden harvest.
Well those are fun to watch,
to pretend you know,
you watched an old jackie chan movie and
it's fucking crazy shit.
But the chunk of masters,
that one.
Yeah,
I was beating them over.
See,
it's out some seed.
It's funny comedy though.
It seems funny.
Yeah.
But it's still,
it's still,
uh,
still there.
and I tell you,
I really liked police story with jackie
chan.
The first one.
That was good.
That was wicked.
That was,
he managed jackie shanghainese.
But a lot of those movies had people
believe in it.
There were people out there that had ci
and depth touch and try,
you know,
when,
when you want.
I just,
I mean,
to bring it back to what you do.
Do you,
do you think there's any of that?
That's hypnosis.
Is there anything that's similar to what
I said Frank Santos used to be able to
do?
Um,
I don't know.
Is it the only slide?
Devotion that they have towards their
sensei or there?
There's,
yeah,
it's bananas.
Honestly.
It's crazy.
They believe what he says.
So he's like,
oh yay,
you can do this and,
but how is that different than a guy who
thinks like,
I watched a guy who thought he was
having sex with madonna and he came in
his pants because Frank Santos put that
in his head and he did that.
I wAtched it and the guy was like,
he didn't know.
He came in and I mean this guy wasn't
that good of an actor.
He just wasn't.
He was embarrassed.
You know what to do.
Hey,
kinda like slumped over and sat and
acquaint.
If he was,
if he was a ham,
he would have spent.
It just was,
you could tell this guy really bad it
at that particular time where he was at
that particular in that particular
place.
He did believe it.
I mean,
you've seen people with needles when
they need,
you know,
they have a needle and they don't feel
the pain you can do,
you can do that.
And there's an interesting one called
pain paradigm,
which I'll talk to you about another
time on,
um,
anticipation next week it was.
And um,
you know,
I mean just at least there's all sorts
of things that we,
who knows what the mindscape we'd only
just now I'm only a postman of
information.
Rarely,
I mean,
what really can meet it,
what will he develop it.
That's an interesting way to describe
it.
A posted minimum from asphalt.
Keith miami,
first teacher said we just posted one of
information.
I like that.
Yeah.
Um,
I,
I just,
I'm really fascinated by the,
the full spectrum,
for lack of a better term of
possibilities of suggestion that you can
go from,
you know,
fake psychics and fake healers.
And like my friend Brian and I were the
comedy store last night.
Did you see that?
Were you there when you saw the woman
was trying to do the reiki healing on
us?
It was hilarious because I knew I was
going to talk to you today and I knew
she was full of shit.
She probably thinks it's real,
but she was like,
can you feel the energy?
I'm like raving.
Like she said,
put your,
put your left hand out.
[inaudible]
left hands are more sensitive,
more susceptible or.
Okay.
So I had my hand out and she is like
running her hand over the top and the
bottom line.
Not touching my hand,
but getting close to it like,
do you feel it?
Do you feel anything?
And I'm like,
nope,
I'm trying.
I'm trying to be open minded but I don't
feel anything.
But some people would be like,
yes,
I do feel it.
I think it's what you want to believe.
My believes like,
like people that say kicks nico to cds,
tarot card readers,
etc.
If they give people comfort,
I make some people feel better and you
know,
right.
Got more power to him.
Right.
More power to them.
They believe at the time if they believe
that there's this reiki,
and then if they believe it and it works
and people are happy doing it and we
might meet,
might go,
well,
it's,
where's the line drawn?
Is the line drawn when you're taking
money from them?
There is pissed take isn't the world.
And they piss take piss takers.
What does,
um,
you know,
taking the piss.
Well,
okay,
you guys are fucking with somebody
taking the piss.
Yeah.
But um,
but more so than that,
someone who is pretending to be healing,
but they're stealing money from you.
They're not really healing you nice.
But it's like anyone that sells a
vitamin that have this snake oil,
snake oil,
yeah,
snake all take this and you'll
definitely changed.
But what about fucking the real placebo
effect?
That's where it gets really weird
because like there are some placebos
they have introduced to people and
they've told them it's a placebo and
then the,
but the act of doing something,
the act of taking something actually has
a more beneficial effect than not doing
anything.
Which is again,
the power of the mind,
like the placebo effect is a real
effect.
You give someone something,
you tell them this is medicine,
this is going to fix whatever ails you.
And it actually does work on a certain
percentage,
a statistically significant percentage
of the people that are like crystals and
shit was like a lot of people believe
in.
They pull up with around and they were
getting good
luck.
Good luck coin.
Yeah.
I've got my lucky quarter dumbo,
isn't it?
You know,
the,
a feather.
Lucky further,
you know,
and he believes he can fly with it.
They're lucky feather.
It comes down to how the rest,
um,
yeah,
he sold it,
I think sold down to your business all
down of what you put into your intention
and what you want to belief for
yourself.
You know,
isn't it
weird that we have these minds that have
such amazing potential,
but there's no fucking real good
guidebook that anybody's handed and
you're sort of supposed to figure it out
on your own or based on if you're lucky.
You have parents that have their shit
together and they sort of give you a
rough outline of how you should live
your life or live by example,
but we're not talking about like
goldfish or swans or anything fucking
simple.
We're talking about human beings with
complex languages in mathematics and
culture and society and laws and and,
and money and all of the weirdness that
comes with being a person in it.
Good.
Though it is
select site in.
Well that is six assignment from a
bloodline of merlin and sherlock.
Yes,
and melon homes.
Real estate.
But that's.
I just liked that.
I didn't,
I just,
I liked the,
I liked the mystery.
I do too because you can see.
You're probably saying,
well,
I like that.
It's interesting and that's what keeps
you,
keeps you going in life.
I think when you find something
interesting and yet you're trying to,
you know,
it's always better to be interested,
interested instead of interesting.
Oh yeah,
no,
for sure.
I mean that's one of the things that I
appreciate most about being able to do
this podcast is that I'm constantly and
consistently inspired and curious.
I'm always learning like this use,
you can't know everything.
It is not possible.
There's too much going on and once you
accept that,
then you just looking for stuff that you
find stimulating and then find more and
more things that you find fascinating
and this podcast has given me this
really unique opportunity to talk to
people like you or know anybody who has
some information that I'm not really
aware of.
Pro.
Massively honored to be on air because
you know,
I'm from.
I'm from liverpool,
I'm from newton.
Yeah,
I know,
but you know,
I'm just like,
yeah,
but you,
nobody's going in there.
And then joe says so nice things in.
Mccall says nice things and I get to do
seminars and get to meet people and I
love it.
I'm just bold enough about them.
well that's what life is all about,
really is finding something like that
that you really enjoy doing and then
pursuing it and then if you can,
god,
if you can make a living doing that,
what a,
what a great way to be,
you know?
Yeah.
I like people.
I like,
you know,
I like people like I don't like everyone
on as a client because some people just
think.
No,
no.
Have you had like people that are like
shitty or just not appreciative,
kind of suss them out quickly?
Do you try to explain to them why you're
not doing this and maybe give them like
some
uh,
yeah,
I hope future.
Yeah.
I just,
yeah,
I just say well I can't.
Or embassy or just the normal stuff and
you know,
it depends on what it is.
It's not often.
I'll be honest with you.
It's not often that happens,
but um,
yeah,
it does happen.
I just handed her the,
you know,
these one guy saying it was one guy
recently.
He's like,
yeah,
everyone in my team thinks I'm rubbish.
I can't fight and I can't talk to you
now.
My wife's in bed and just like,
oh,
that don't know.
Right.
You know,
just loads of things you have to stop.
No,
that's too much work.
Like if you can't see what she has salt,
no sovereignty.
I see much hustle.
Yeah.
But like on the docks triumphant,
I like that everyone had a gym.
I know people that went didn't win
fights on the door jams and they went
under me.
I like,
ah,
casey,
she's good.
So then I would just give them that
boston,
you feel good about it,
you sort of thing.
Yes,
I've achieved something that other
people didn't like that.
Right?
Yeah.
The ability to help people.
And the,
the satisfaction that comes from other
people benefiting from your efforts?
Yeah.
Is a very nice thing.
A light.
It's in a question lady called donna
tainter at the minute.
She's soft got where she is somewhere in
the states and she's,
they rarely.
Well it's just a transformation has been
incredible.
And she's,
you know,
all the students are so much better to
have sponsors like really warm inserters
you ride in better and stuff like that.
And he's just moving things out of
people's way is kicking out.
All right.
So if people want to get ahold of you,
what is the best way your twitter handle
is?
Vinny shoreman.
What is it?
What do they need?
Shelter.
The reason why it's called shelter,
I'm it's not perverted in 69 shell time
as I used to be a comment say for 16
hours.
The arrows bond.
Oh no,
that's a problem,
right?
Isn't it?
That number.
So it's gonna have to change that.
I think a lot of great cars.
Nineteen 69.
We landed on the moon
and you can get me on vinny shoreman.com
and also you can get me on facebook.
There's a,
there's a facebook or mind coaching page
where there is techniques and videos,
a withdrawal techniques and all sorts.
Beautiful.
It was a pleasure.
I really appreciate it.
I do this again sometime here in
California.
I'll be back very soon because liam
harrison's fight in my light pattern on
the house is fighting romeo dones and
him coming over with them.
What is that?
July the 31st to fight it.
So I'll be over before.
Is that taking place?
Um,
I'm not too sure.
California.
So wiring kelly.
Really?
Okay.
Maybe I'll go to the fights.
I'd like to see it as.
Awesome.
Beautiful.
thank you.
I really,
really appreciate it.
Thank you very much.
In his friends will be back next week.
Lots of great and entertaining guests.
Not as entertaining as this
motherfucker,
but we'll try see you soon.